jonathan rue has created many popular
and best-selling software courses in
this free course he will teach you how
to use the kivy library to create games
with python
you already learned the python
programming language you have the basics
and you are able to create your own
programs with python but now what are
the next steps how to improve your
skills to the next level and be able to
create more powerful applications with a
graphical user interface that can run on
any platforms ios android mac windows
yes it's possible to create games
desktop and mobile applications with one
single long-wait python and for that we
are going to use the tv library tv lets
you create games desktop and mobile
applications by sharing the same source
code in python for every platform that's
very powerful in this tutorial i will
teach you everything you need to know
about tv step by step you will learn
about the widgets to create user
interfaces with buttons labels images
and so on you will use all kinds of
layouts for placement strategies and ui
that can automatically adapt to every
screen sizes mobile desktop and tablets
and you will also learn about the canvas
so you can draw anything you want on the
screen lines rectangle circles at 60
frames per second and finally you will
practice your new skills with a real
world project that we will create from a
to z
the galaxy project galaxy
galaxy is a perspective game where you
need to keep your spaceship on the track
you will learn how to display everything
in perspective how to create an
algorithm to generate the land how to
manage screen touch keypress and how to
play sounds and all of this runs on mac
windows ios and android so are you ready
let's start
[Music]
hi i'm jonathan with python you can
create graphical user interfaces with
many different libraries you have tick
inter which automatically comes with the
installation of python it's easy but not
very powerful you have qt which is good
to make feature-rich interfaces with
many kind of widgets but it comes with a
commercial license there is also pygame
which is more specific to 2d games for
windows and mac and finally there is kv
it's based on opengl so the graphics are
fast and it supports all the platforms
linux windows mac os android ios and
even raspberry that's the library i
choose to teach you here because it's
easy versatile and powerful this
tutorial is made up of two parts part
one you will learn the kiwi library with
the lab project that will be our
programming laboratory part two you will
practice your skills with the galaxy
project in the lab project you are going
to learn how to use the layouts the
widgets and the canvas for the galaxy
project we will progress with three
versions version one we will manage the
perspective the movements and the key
press version two we will generate the
land display the spaceship and manage
the collisions and version three we will
finalize the project with a menu add the
game over state manage the score display
images and play sounds but just before i
will show you the installation and setup
of qv for your project so that you will
have a basic structure that you can
always reuse for any project also you
can follow this tutorial for pc windows
or mac to follow this tutorial you have
to know the basics of python the
variables the functions the conditions
the classes the loops and also you have
to be familiar with a programming
environment like visual studio code or
pycharm if that's not the case i invite
you to look at my python beginner
tutorial on my youtube channel code with
jonathan you will find the link in the
description or you can find also some
python tutorials here on freecodecamp ok
let's start with the project creation
and installation of tv let's do it
i am going to show you how to create
your project and how to install kivy in
this course i will use pycharm but i
will also show you with visual studio
code and you can follow the same steps
on mac or pc windows if you are on
visual studio code you create a new file
you create a new folder
lab ok and you will name your file main
dot py for every project you will name
your file main dot py okay with pycharm
you will click on new project then we
will call it qv the lab i advise you to
use the virtual environment but if you
are on pc windows it's better to use an
interpreter directly because it was some
issues with the virtual off and of
course you need to select a version of
python python 3 dot something minimal
version 3.7 you can use 3.7 3.8 3.9 3.10
if you have no interpreter here you can
click on this button system interpreter
and then you select your version of
python of course if python is not
installed on your machine i advise you
to go on my youtube channel called with
jonathan there is a tutorial here that
will explain you all the steps to set up
your machine and to install python okay
in my case i will select the virtual
environment and i will take a version of
python 3.9 create you will get this
interface so in some case it will create
a main.py directly if it's not the case
you can right click here on your project
and make a new python file that you will
call main.py in our case we are just
going to remove the breakpoint here and
to remove all the code okay now we are
going to install the kivy library i will
show you first on pycharm and then on
visual studio code you will click here
on terminal and then you will type ice
on minus minus version in my case it's
3.9.2 that's correct we need to be sure
we use a python 3 version and then i
will type pip install qv enter when it's
complete you will type pip lists
enter and then you can see on the list
that kivi has been installed on visual
studio code you will click here on
terminal new terminal and you will have
this interface here you will type python
minus minus version and as you can see i
have a version of python 2.7 as a
default because i am on mac on pc
windows normally you should have
installed python version 3 something but
if you are on mac you will need to type
python 3 minus minus version ok in my
case it displays python 3.9.2
so take care here you will need to make
sure that visual studio code is using
the same version here on the lower left
part here i need to select a python
3.9.2 so if i scroll down you can see i
have two versions of python 3.9.2 i need
to use the right one to do that i will
type which python3 and i can see the
right path here python.framework so this
is this version that i will select here
if you are on pc windows which does not
exist but you can type where python to
get the pass of your python interpreter
also in visual studio code make sure
that you have installed the python
extension here else you will not have
the possibility to play the file again i
explain you all of that in my python
tutorial on my youtube channel ok now we
are going to write some code that is
going to be the basic structure that you
will always use with any project with tv
i will write it on pycharm if you are on
visual studio code you just write the
same lines of code the first thing is to
create a class and that will be the base
class of our application and we are
going to call it the lab and for every
applications with kv you need to add
app at the end so it's going to be the
lab app okay take care of the upper case
then we will inherit from the app class
define in kivy i add semicolon and this
class is going to be empty at the
beginning okay you can see that we have
to include the app it's not referenced
yet so for this either you click here
import qv up app but if you are on
visual studio code you will need to
write this manually take care because
this is kv.app lowercase import app with
an uppercase and then we are going to
start our empty application so we will
have an empty screen we will do this so
that we can test if our application can
initialize properly so what you will do
is that you will take zlab app and you
will add some parenthesis dot run
parenthesis take care because if you
forget the parenthesis here and if you
write this it's not going to work you
need to instantiate the class create an
object and on this object you will run
it okay on visual studio code you do
exactly the same thing and then you will
click on the play if you don't have the
play here at the first time you will do
a right click and click run okay and in
my case i have a black screen that means
everything is working fine on visual
studio code you do the exact same thing
and then you click on the play and if it
says no module name kivy that means you
forgot to install kivy in that case you
need to type pip install remember that
on the mac you need to type pip3
install tv okay and then i can click on
the play and i get this black screen
which means everything is okay at this
stage if you cannot get the black screen
and if you get an error that says cannot
get a window provider that means you
have a problem with your graphic display
first you have to know that you cannot
start tv in a virtual machine it's not
going to work and sometimes you cannot
start tv on an external display and also
if it's not working on windows you can
upgrade your graphic card drivers okay
just before we continue we are going to
define the main interface of our program
and we are going to call it the main
widget you will write class
main widget
and it will inherit from the widget
class semicolon pass
and you need to include kv dot uix dot
widget dot widget again take care here
it's an upper case and if you are on
visual studio code you will need to
write this line here we still need to
complete a few steps you are going to
create a new file you will right click
on the name of your project don't right
click on vrv but create your new file
here it's not going to be a python file
it's a file and you will call it with
the exact same name of your application
the lab but you don't put app after you
will just put dot kv like kivy this file
make sure that this file is in the same
directory as the main python file
this file will be the definition of our
graphical interface it's inside that
file that we will explain what we want
to display it's also possible to create
our graphical interface and directly
from the code but you will see that it's
more easy to do it directly from the kv
file and it's also interesting because
you will make a separation between your
graphical definitions and the logic of
your code inside this kv file we are
going to explain what is the main
interface and for us the main interface
is this main widget in the next video i
will show you how to add buttons and
labels inside our main widget but for
now we are going to keep it empty so i
will just take main widget and i will
put it here at the beginning of the file
and put a semicolon so this says that
the main interface is the main widget if
you start your program you can still see
an empty screen this is normal because
we did not define anything to display
that's all for the base structure of
your kv project if you look at some code
on internet you will see some
differences for example we don't need to
call it main widget and also we can use
some layouts directly here instead of
the widget i will show you how to do
that later and also it's not mandatory
to use a kv file you can do everything
inside the code and in that case you
will need to use a function that is
called build and that will return
directly the main widget however i
recommend you to do exactly what we did
here and to use a kv file and that's all
for the configuration of our project
let's continue
everything is okay for the installation
of tv at this stage if you had any
issues first try to search for your
error on google and if you don't find
any information write a comment just
below this video with your exact error
message and i will reply you okay just
before we continue let's download the
resources pack for this tutorial you
will find the link in the description or
you can directly go to my website code
with jonathan.net resources tv in this
zip file you will find some images
sounds and fonts that we will need later
and also all the source code of the
project so that it can also help if you
are getting some errors because you can
compare your source code and mine and
spot any differences okay let's move to
part number one in the lab project i
will first tell you more about that
project and then we will go straight
into the code let's do it
[Music]
the lab project layout version this is a
beginner project i'm going to show you a
demo of this project right now first we
will learn how to display some widget on
the screen like buttons and labels and
to change some properties like the
colors the position and the size then we
will create some examples on how to
organize our content stacking vertically
stacking horizontally using some grids
and embedding previous content and also
generating items by writing some codes
and to use a scroll view the objective
is to start your practice about kivy you
will learn about the base structure of a
kv project and you will learn how to use
kv files where we can describe our user
interface then i will show you how to
use some basic widgets like the button
and the label and to modify some of
their properties but the most important
is to learn how to create interface that
can adapt to every screen size desktop
mobile and tablet and that's where we
are going to learn and focus mainly
about the layouts also as a good
practice we will use size and position
that use only density independent pixels
i will explain you how to do that the
steps first create the project and learn
about the base structure of qv project
then i will show you how to display some
widgets and then we will focus on
placement strategies layouts concerning
the layout we will progress in six steps
step number one box layout box layout
makes it possible to stack the elements
vertically or horizontally second step
onshore layout you can put your content
in every corner of the screen or in the
center third step grid layout you
organize your content with a number of
columns or a number of rows step number
four stack layout stack layout is
another way of stacking the items but
you will go to a next line and it can
also stack items of different size step
number five i will show you how to use a
scroll view to be able to scroll when
the content is bigger than the window
size we can scroll vertically or
horizontally and step number six page
layout i will show you how to reuse some
of the previous examples that we have
created and to show them like a book we
will be able to slide from one side to
another to display all different layouts
other layouts exist in kivy you have the
float layout the relative layout and the
scatter layout concerning the front
layout it's quite close to what we are
going to see in the first part by using
the widget so i did not reuse it here in
the examples the relative layout has
only an interest when using with a
canvas so we will use that layout in the
canvas section of this project and the
scatter layout is very specific to
particular use that is not relevant here
so i did not use it in my list are you
ready to start with this project let's
do it
now we are going to see how to display
something in the screen we have our
black screen and now we want to add some
content i will show you how to add a
button and also a label and we are going
to add that inside our main widget
because our main widget is our main
interface so now i'm going to show you
how to define the main widget and how to
explain what we want to display inside
our widget to do this we are going to
use this syntax to explain this is the
definition of our main widget and inside
i'm going to use the tab and then i will
say we have a button so you will use
button with a b
uppercase semicolon and inside the
button again you use the tabs you can
use some properties for example text
semicolon and then we put a value for
the text for example hello
take care because in the kv file we
never use the equal sign we don't write
that we use only the semicolon okay
let's start this
you can see that in our window we have
our hello button at the bottom here and
we can click on it we don't have any
action on the click button yet i will
show you later how to manage the click
of the button just a small thing before
i comment on the button sometimes with
spy charm you will see that when you
start your program your window will not
be selected it's going to be greyed here
and it's not going to be possible to
click on the button if this happens you
just select pycharm again and select
your window again and it will be okay
this is only related to pycharm and this
does not affect the fact that your
program is working correctly okay let's
go back to the button you can see the
button is displayed on the lower left
part of the screen and even if i resize
my window it's always the case that's
because the default coordinates are 0 0
0 for the x and 0 for the y when you
increase the y you will go upper and
when you increase the x you will go on
the right the default size for the
button is 100 pixels and 100 pixels so
let's change that for example i can use
the size property and i can give 400
pixels width and 200 pixels height let's
try it you can see that this time my
button is bigger okay and we can also
move the button by using position
position for example 100 for the x
and 200 for the y okay so we change 100
here and 200 here perfect
let me show you something important all
the dimensions here the size and the
positions are in pixels but because we
are going to work on multiple platforms
computers mobile phones tablets you will
see that the screens have different
pixels density and for example 400
pixels will be displayed very big in
some screens or very small in other
screens depending on the pixel density
and we don't want such difference
between every display we want something
more homogeneous so you are not going to
use the pixels but always the mdp done
ct independent pixels to use the dp you
are going to use this syntax dp 400dp
dp okay and for the position it's going
to be the same 100 p 200 dp so 400 dp is
a lot and i'm going to show you 40 by
40. the size ndp corresponds to a
physical size for example if i use 40 by
40 dp for my button and if i start this
it's going to be the size of a finger
you see this my window is like
deactivated so if it happens to you you
click on pycharm window and then you
click again on your window and now it's
working and now i can click on my button
that's what i told you previously so to
go back to the dp 40 dp by 40 dp is the
size of a finger touch okay and it's
going to be the exact same size on every
device if we start this on a mobile
phone on the tablet it's going to be
always the same physical size okay let's
have a bigger size here 100 and for
example 80.
and let's add another button to do this
i'm just going to copy paste this button
and i will say
text hello to if i restart my program
you can see that we only see hello to
button and that's because it is at the
same position and the same size of the
first hello button it's just on top of
the previous button and this is because
you first draw this button and then this
second button on top so we need to
change the position for example for
position 200 and 300 and let's see what
it gives so now my second button is
displayed here let's continue so now we
use only the button widget i'm going to
show you how to use a label for example
i'm going to change this button by a
label the label only displayed text on
the screen and it used the same
properties as the button so we can reuse
text property and the size and the
position and if i start this you can see
that now i display a label the label
does not have any interaction with the
user it's just a display on the screen
we can use also some other properties
like the color color is going to be rgb
a g b red green blue and a alpha so you
need to separate with a comma and for
each component you are going to give a
value between 0 and 100
so it's going to be between 0 and 1. and
if you want to be halfway it's going to
be 0.5 for example here i want to
display a right color so i'm going to
give 100 red zero percent green and zero
percent blue and for the alpha i will
say that it's 100 percent visible if i
do this you can see that my label is
displayed in red i can also apply this
property for the button so i can copy
paste this and let's say that for the
button we want something blue so i will
put blue here red green blue okay and
you can see that the text of my button
is blue for the background of the button
i will show you later in this course how
to change the color or how to display an
image in the button that's all for now
for the display of these first controls
i will show you later how to use other
widgets and also how to use other
properties but now let's focus on the
layouts because you can see that if i
resize my window then the controls size
and positions are not adapted to the
window and that maybe i cannot see
everything that i want to display with
the layouts we are going to have a
placement strategy to have a display
that adapts to every screen size
let's start with the layout first i will
show you how to use a box layout and i
will show you how to use it by writing
the code in python and also by using the
kv file so you will see the two syntax
let's go back to the project previously
we have created our main widget it's our
main interface here and we have
displayed a button and a label so now we
are going to create a new class that is
going to be our box layout
example which is not a widget but its
box layout okay and i can write pass for
now we need to import box layout in key
ui x and box i would import box layout
okay how can i change my main interface
if i start my program i can still see my
button and my label coming from the main
widget so i need to replace my main
interface by the box layout example the
main interface can be either a widget or
either a layout if i restart this time i
have an empty screen so now we are going
to add some buttons inside our box
layout i will first show you how to do
this with the code and then with the kv
file usually we only use the kv file but
here i want to show you the two syntax
and you will see that in some case it's
useful because later with the stack
layout for example i will show you how
to add 100 button and we will use a loop
inside the code so for some specific
case it's useful to know the syntax in
the code first let's create the init
function def init our constructor take
care because with kv the constructor
takes also another argument star star
key w args we are not going to use this
argument but it is for the internal
working of kiwi so it's like this when
you use super but init and you also pass
star star kw arcs okay here in the init
i will create a first button for example
i can use b1 variable it is going to be
a button and button we need to import it
in tv uix button so this line also i can
pass some properties to my button i can
pass them directly in the constructor of
the button for example text equal a you
remember previously that we created
button in the kv file this way we use a
text property but we use semicolon to
give the value here in the code we use
the equal sign the names of the widgets
and the name of the properties are the
same with the kv file okay so let's
create also a second button button
number two with the text b how can i add
these buttons inside my layout so myself
self this class is a box layout so we
can do self dot add widget i want to add
a widget inside my layout i add the
button one and also i can add the
button too let's restart our program and
see what it give you can see we have our
two buttons button a and button b and
they are very big that's because in fact
the layout will use all the space of the
window because and that's our main
interface here it will take all the
window space the box rear root is going
to stack the different elements first we
gave the button one with a and then we
gave the button b so it's going to stack
the different elements horizontally as a
default behavior but we can also change
the orientation i will show you how to
do that for example if i add a third
button button c that is the number three
okay you can see that this next button
has been stacked on the right and you
can also see that if i resize my window
everything is adapted correctly also as
a default for the size of the different
buttons the size will be equal between
all the buttons but we will see how to
change that later also the order of the
add widget is important for example if i
do add widget at the end you will see
that the button a is on the right
because first i added button b then the
c and then the a okay
let's go back to this configuration and
i'm going to show you how to use the
orientation property if i want to change
the orientation of my box layout i can
do a self dot orientation as a default
it's horizontal but if i put vertical
you can see that now i'm stacking
vertically my different elements okay
let's comment all this code and let's do
the equivalent of this inside the kv
file so i will comment using this syntax
okay and because i have removed all the
code i need to put pass
to say that it's normal that we don't
have any code here okay so now if i
restart i have an empty screen in the kv
file how can i add buttons to my box iot
example i'm going to copy this and i'm
going to define
my box layout example and i will say
that inside i have a button button a
okay if i restart you can see we have
one button taking all the screen then i
can add button
b and button c
and you can see it stacking my three
buttons okay and i can also use the
orientation property orientation to
vertical if i want to stack vertically
okay so here we only used buttons in the
layout but you can use also other
widgets for example i can use label here
instead i can use any widget in my
layout but i will mostly use the button
because it has a background and we can
really see where it is located also it's
possible to embed other layouts inside a
layout instead of putting a button b
here i can put another box layout or i
can put another kind of layout here we
will do that in the next lecture also
how can i resize a button you can see
that the layout is taking care of the
position of the elements and of the size
of the element but can i change that
previously we saw how to use the size
for example so if i say that my button a
has a size of 40 dp
width and 40dp height is it going to
work let's try and you can see that it's
not working at all it totally ignored
this property it was working in the
widget in the widget we could use the
size and the post properties and it was
working fine that's because a widget is
not taking care of the position and the
size of the element the layout does so
it will as a default ignore post and
size properties but you may say yes but
we still want to control the size for
example we want this button to be
smaller than the other button and we may
want to change also its position we can
do that and that's what we are going to
do in the next lecture
previously we saw how to use a box
layout by adding some widget inside it
and you also learned that the layout is
responsible for the position and the
size of the different widgets and also
we saw that we could not use the size
property it was not working inside the
layout because the layout is controlling
the size here i'm going to show you how
to use new properties so we can control
the size and the position of the
elements inside a layout and for this
you are not going to use size and
position but you are going to use
size hint
first you can see that i can use the
hash sign to do some commands in the kv
file size hint is going to be a
proportion for example i'm going to give
80 percent for the width and
50 for the height so what do we have you
can see that for my a button i get
eighty percent of the original reads and
i get also 50
compared to the other controls so the
percentage is a proportion with the
other controls
b has a height that is twice the height
of a as a default you will have one and
one if i go back to one and one i get
the normal behavior and for example
let's say that i'm going to get
only 50 percent height like i just did
previously
okay and now i'm going to say that b
will have twice the height
and you can see that now b is twice the
height of c height of c is one height of
b is two and height of a is 0 5 these
size are proportions and you can see
that the proportions are kept if i
resize the window is it possible to use
fixed value for the size you can do that
but you need to say you go in manual
mode that means you say to the layout
you don't want him to manage the size
and to do this you are going to use none
so i'm going to put none for the reads
and for the hate and that way i can use
the size property is going to take it
into account now if i restart you can
see my button is 40 by 40 or for example
i can use
160 for example and you can see that the
size is fixed for example if i resize
the window it's not changing the size
also i want to show you that we can
write this line a different way and i
will comment it okay if i restart my
program i will have the default size 100
per 100 okay i can specify separately
the width and the height i can write
widths
100 dp and i can write the height
60 dp okay let's try it and you can see
i get the size that we get previously
but now let's say i want to have 100
weeds and only have a fixed height
so i can mix between the two i will keep
my
fixed height of 60 dp but for the width
i will keep 100
okay let's try it you can see i have one
hundred percent width and i have fixed
height
now i'm going to show you that we can
also change the position for example if
i put a width of 50
you can see that my button is display on
the left how can i move it to the right
i can use plus hint
pause hint is also a percentage but it's
going to be a different syntax it's a
dictionary you will use some components
x
center x and right for the horizontal
and y
center y and top for the vertical for
horizontal or vertical you need to pick
only one you cannot specify x and also
the right at the same time and for the
vertical you can also pick only one of
the three in my case i want to control
the horizontal position for these
components you need to give a percentage
between 0 and 100 it's going to be a
value between 0 and 1. for example if i
use x and i say x is equal to 0 then my
button is displayed on the left like we
have previously because the x is the
left part of the button and we say it is
equal to zero now i say that x is
for example ten percent you can see that
my button moved to ten percent of the
width of the window now i can move to
fifty percent
now my button is on the right because
the width of my button is 50 and because
i gave the position of the x to be the
center of the window 50
the button is displayed here if i give
75 percent for example you can see my
button begins to be drawn at 75 percent
and it's a little bit out of the window
and of course if i give one 100 percent
the button is totally out of the window
because the left part of the button is
just here at 100
the same way i can use right
and right is not the left part of the
button but the right part of the button
and if i give 100 for the right part my
button is displayed here because the
right part is here it's at 100 percent
and if i give it to 50
you can see my button is here because
the right part is at 50 percent of the
screen okay i can use also center x to
50 percent now the button is centered
because the center x is the center of
the button and we say that the center of
the button is at 50 percent of the
window and it's going to work the same
way for the vertical part so for example
if i stack horizontally i can just
command this or i can write horizontal
okay i will remove this property and i
will just comment everything here so we
get
for example just 50
and 50
okay we have something like this and i'm
going to say i want to draw my button at
the top of the window i can use a post
hint and put top to one
so the top of my button is at the top of
the window 100
i can also use center y equal 0.5 for
example okay so it's the same logic for
the vertical part that's all concerning
the size hint and the pause hint
remember that you need to use these
properties to control the position and
the size inside the layout and if you
want to use a fixed size you use a
non-value and then you can use size
property let's continue on the project
you will see that the kv syntax is a
good way to build up your interface very
quickly and it's also possible to create
widgets and layouts directly from the
code i will show you that in a bit later
you might ask me but what can we do with
is it only for games or can we make a
full application and also is it possible
to customize all the interface
yes i will show you a bit later how to
customize the colors the fonts and the
styles of any widget but let me show you
first some of the projects that i did
with kivy i already told you about the
galaxy project that we will do together
in this tutorial it mainly uses canvas
for drawing the game and some layouts
and widgets for the menu another project
that i created is mr beat it's a
software bitbox that uses real-time
audio so that you can play any resumes
with any sounds that you want this
project is from my python full course if
you are interested you can find the link
in the description and it will also
appear here it uses more widgets and
more layouts also the interface is
totally styled and polished we have this
lcd effect here you can light the
buttons it also uses a scroll view for
the tracks and it perfectly adapts to
any screen sizes the ui is made from a
combination of kv syntax and python code
it's a good project if you want to go a
step further with the tv library also i
have published the galaxy and mrbit
project on the ios and android store so
you can download them and try them right
now okay let me show you a last project
the pizza project it looks more simple
but it is more focused on the data
management the pizza menu that you see
comes from a web server developed with
django so the app is not static it will
display the updated data if you add a
new pizza or if you change the price of
a pizza for example the complete project
jungle server plus the tv app is also
part of my full python course ok let's
go back to our code i will show you how
to combine multiple layouts
i am going to show you how to embed a
layout inside a layout for example here
we are going to replace the b button
with a box layout containing four
buttons stacked vertically how we can do
that you remember that our main layout
here is stacking three elements button a
button b and label c button b we want to
replace it and we are going to stack a
box layout here instead
inside this box layout we are going to
put a button b1 a button
b2 b3 and b4 and we are going to stack
them vertically so i'm going to use
orientation in this box layout to
vertical if i start it you can see i
have my a button first then i stack this
box layout containing
four buttons and then i stack my c label
for this box layout it's only stacking
three elements in this button this box
layout and this label and inside this
box layout we stack all different
elements here i have used a box layout
inside the box layout but of course you
can mix and use different kinds of
layouts and also you can embed at
different levels inside this box layout
i can also put another layout inside and
inside so you can have multiple levels
of embedding one last thing i want to
show you is that we can use a spacing
property to space the different items
for example here for the box i hoot i
can type spacing and give 10 dp so let's
see what it gives and you can see i have
some space between my different elements
and that's all for the embedding of the
layout let's continue
we have completed the first step with
the box tryout and we move to the second
step onshore layout so we are going to
create a new class class that we are
going to call onshore layout example
that come from an onshore layout and you
will need to import it
import qvuix onto our layout onshore
layout okay and i will write pass
then i will go back to my kv file and i
will say that it's going to be the main
interface of course if i restart now i
don't have anything in my window and of
course we are not losing what we did
previously if i want to see my main
widget i can just replace my main
interface here and i can see the
previous examples that we did previously
okay and later in this course i will
show you how to create a menu with
multiple screens and we will be able to
navigate inside the application to all
our different examples but for now we
just do it manually okay i'm going to
start on the onshore layout let's define
it
inside it i'm going to put a button with
a text
that is a okay let's try it you can see
that my onshore layout took all the
space that will be the case every time
for the layout and inside it i put a
button that also took all the space so
it's not interesting here because i want
to change the position of that button
inside the screen so we need to give a
size to this a button
how can i do that i will need to use
size
hint and i will say i give 10 percent
reads and 10 percent hate okay let's try
it you see that as a default on the
button is at the center of the layout
now i'm going to show you new properties
that we are going to use only for the
onshore layout it's unsure x and unsure
y
and these properties can get different
values for example right left and center
for the x and bottom
top center for the y as a default it's
center and center so let's say that for
the x for example i give right
and that i don't define
the answer y what is it going to give
you can see that now my button is on the
right
and as a default we are still in the
center of the wire take care because the
onshore layout takes all the space and
this
just defines where he will place the
child elements the widget we put inside
but of course if we use two buttons for
example button a and button b they are
going to occupy the same space it's no
stacking here it's not like a box layout
the behavior of this layout is different
so button b is just above the button a
you can see that if i use two
and two here my button a is just below
okay but for now let's just go back to
the previous positions so i'm just going
to comment on the button b okay so my
button a is on the right center of the
screen how can i display it to the top
left corner for example in the x i will
use
left and then i will activate onshore y
and i will give top
okay
so it's top left
good okay i can use for example the
bottom here
and the center for the x
bottom center okay
so let's keep for example the top
and center horizontally this one so i
previously show you that the difference
elements are not stacked so how can i
display two buttons then i can stack my
two buttons in a box layout okay and
this box layout is going to be displayed
at the top center of course i need to
give a size to my box layout so i'm
going to
give size hand to this box layout and to
remove
size hint in the buttons okay let's try
that you see i have my box layout taking
20 percent and 20
of the screen size and inside it i have
my two buttons that's all that i wanted
to show you for the onshore layout
we have completed the step 2 onshore
layout and we move to the grid layout
with the grid layout you can organize
content with columns and rows so let's
create our new example grid
layout example that comes from a grid
layout ok so again you will need to
import it import import kv uix grid
layout okay so now let's change the main
interface with the grid layout and let's
define
our grid layout example first i want to
show you something new we are not
obliged to do this we did this to
explain that our grid layout example is
a grid layout and we need that in the kv
file else he will not know about our
grid layout example but we can use a
small shortcut if we don't want to use
the coding python and that's the case
here because we will keep it with pass
we can just command that and give the
parent class directly here in the
definition by using the add sign and put
the parent class directly that's exactly
the same so this time we don't need to
use that and of course we could do that
with our other example previously except
with the box layout example because we
wanted to use some code here so finally
if you change your miner if you want to
implement some code you will go you will
need to revert and to remove that and to
uncommand this code and write your code
here but in this case we will keep it
like this
grid layout let's add some content
button text
a and we are going to add a few buttons
b and c okay if i start like this it's
not really working you can see that the
buttons are displayed here because this
layout needs two mandatory properties
it's rows number of rows or number of
columns you must specify one of these
two properties for example
we say that we have two columns in that
case i have a b and then c we have two
columns of course if i say only
one colon it's going to behave like a
box layout we have only one column and
if i say we have three columns it's also
going to be the same as a box layout
except that we stack horizontally so i'm
going to put more buttons inside d
e and f
okay i keep the three columns and in
that case i get a grid like this and i
can also use the rows it's going to work
the same way so i can use rows and say
for example we have two rows
and i'm going to get this result okay
that's fine now let's say that we want
to change the size of this first column
how can i do that i can resize the a
button with a size hint and i'm going to
give 50 horizontally and 100 vertically
if i restart you see that it's not
working because the d button still have
a 100 percent so the colon will still
use 100 but if i copy this to the d
button
then because i have the a and the d
button to 50
the colon can resize to 50 percent so
it's still a proportion but we can have
a fixed value if i use none instead and
if i use a reads for example
16dp and i copy paste that on the d
button let's try it you can see that
this time it's fixed value on the left
the last thing i want to show you is
that again we can embed a layout inside
the gray layout and for example we are
going to replace the b button so we
already know that we can replace that by
a box layout for example but we can do
even better than that if i go back to my
previous examples and for example if i
get the box layout example box layout
example is also a box layout so i can
pick it directly and put it in my grid
layout instead of the button b i will
put my box layout example and if i
restart this you can see that in this
cell i have my box i wrote example
stacking the a button this second box
diode and the c label and this second
box layout that stacks the elements
vertically so you can see that this is
very easy and very powerful that's all
that i wanted to show you with the grid
layout let's continue on the project
we have completed the third step on the
grid layout and we move on to the stack
layout i will create my new stack layout
example and this time i will also create
it in the code because we are going to
use a kv file but also we are going to
write some code so i will do stack
layout from stack layout and of course
you need to import it okay then i will
change my main interface and i will
define my stack layout example the stack
layout is stacking the elements but not
the same way as a box layout the box
layout is only in one line and it will
make all the elements fit in this one
line or one row but the stack layout
will stack the items on multiple lines
and you need to give the size of each
item and each item can have a different
size and also i will show you how to
change the orientation so let's start by
putting a button text and it's going to
be a button okay so if i start you can
see that here i have an error and why do
i have an error can you see it says it
cannot parse this line because you
should never use uppercase on properties
so it's text with a small t okay let's
restart you can see that my button is
taking all the space because the stack
layout does not manage the size of the
items so we need to specify a size with
size hint and let's say that this button
will take only 20 percent horizontally
and vertically let's try it so i have my
a button at the top left corner and we
are going to add some more buttons
b
and c b
c you can see it's stacking the elements
this way and if i resize the window the
buttons are always 20
of the size of the window so what
happens if i add three more buttons d
e
and f
you can see he was able to stack five
button of twenty percent because it
makes one hundred percent and then he
went to the next line perfect so now
let's continue and let's add some more
buttons but i want to add them with the
code because for example i want to add
10 button or 100 buttons so we are going
to use a loop so i will keep all my
buttons here in the kv file but i will
also begin to write some code here def
init
with also the star star kw x and you
have to call super init
by passing the kwx okay this is a basic
structure for the constructor then i can
begin to write my code how to create a
button and to add it in my stack layout
and we saw that previously i can create
a button b
button and i can give some properties
here so text for example is going to be
z and i want to add it in my layout so i
can do self dot add widget and i add
this b button if i start that you can
see that the z button is taking all the
space because as a default he will use a
size hand of 1 n1 so we need to change
that and i can use a comma and size
hint equal to tuple that is 20
and 20
let's try again what's interesting here
is that you can see that the z button
was the first one i did in the layout
then i had the abcd and that's because
init is called at first so first you
will do that and after
he will do what is in the kv file okay
so just to make it more simple here i
will delete what i have in the kv file
and i will keep only my
z button okay now i want to create
multiple buttons so i will use a loop i
will loop here for i in
range let's say we want to create 10
buttons 0 to 10 and inside my loop for
each time we loop we will create a
button and we will add it in the layout
of course for the text i want to change
and i want to display the value of i
and because i don't want to start with 0
i'm going to display i plus one to start
from one so let's try again you can see
i have
ten buttons and i can resize my window
perfect now our buttons use twenty
percent width and twenty percent height
what happens if i use a fixed value for
the size i'm going to do that so i'm
going to put none
and none for the size hint and i'm going
to give a size property equal to a tuple
and it's going to be for example 100 dp
in the code you need to use ndp
parenthesis 100 and you need to import
that import
from qv.matrix
okay and then i will use a comma for the
height and use dp of 100 okay let's try
it i restart my program and i have my 10
buttons but if i resize the window you
can see that the elements are stacked
differently because it's a fixed size of
the elements actually i don't need to
stack elements of the same size and for
example if i change the size here and
let's say we use a size variable that is
going to be dp of 100 plus
we are going to use the value of i
multiplied by 10 for example so we have
different size for our buttons so i'm
going to change that here and you will
see that it every button has a different
size and we have something like this
okay anyway let's go back to a fixed
size so i'm going to put back size equal
dp 100 size is not the property here
it's just a local variable okay i can
use any name for this variable so i want
to show you a few more things the
orientation you can see that we begin to
stack from the left to the right and
from the top to the bottom but we can
change that behavior with orientation
property so i can use the orientation
property from the code directly or from
the kv file on my stack layout i will
start with the kv file orientation
orientation is not only horizontal or
vertical for the stack layout it's a
little bit more complex than that you
can select two stack you can select to
stack from left to right and also from
top to bottom and you are going to give
a string that is a contraction of that
that is
left to right and top to bottom this is
the default orientation but if i want to
start from
right to left
i can change that and it's going to
stack from right to left and top to
bottom okay if i change here to bottom
to top
you can see that it's taking from right
to left and from bottom to top and of
course i can do the last one from left
to right and from bottom to top left to
right and bottom to top okay and it's
also possible to use this in the code so
i'm going to show you the equivalent of
that you will do here in your init
self dot orientation equal and you put
the same value that we did previously
okay next thing i want to show you is
that we can use a padding value a
padding is an internal margin so we can
use padding and you will give 4 value
the top
padding 20 dp the left padding 20 dp
then the top padding 40 dp is going to
be a clockwise from
left top right bottom okay but usually
we put the same values for the different
area so i'm going to put 20 dp all
around and we're going to try that now
you can see in this padding effect this
internal margin okay
so i'm going to remove it and i'm going
to show you a last thing we saw
previously the spacing with the box
layout to put some space between the
different elements and i can give a
spacing horizontally and vertically for
example 20 dp horizontally and 20 dp
vertically okay let's try it and you can
see i have a margin between all my
different elements okay one last thing
for example i will go back to the
default orientation so i will command
that and i will also comment the spacing
so we go back to our 10 buttons like
this and what happens if i decide to put
100 buttons let's try it you can see i
don't have enough space in my window i
can expand the window to display more
items but
i cannot display the 100 items to solve
that we are going to use what we call a
scroll view that will make the
possibility to scroll in the window and
that's what we are going to do in the
next lecture
we have completed the step number four
with the stack layout and now we move to
the scroll view previously we have
created a stack layout and we have 100
items that we cannot display in the
window so we are going to add a scroll
view so we are able to scroll and see
all the items i will go to the kv file
and i'm going to create my
scroll
view example that comes from a scroll
view okay inside the scroll view i'm
going to put my stack layout example you
can see that scroll view does not have a
name of layout that's because it's a bit
different because it can take only one
child in our case the child is stuck
layout example so let's move to this
interface scroll view example and
restart our program we can still see our
stack layout but we can still not scroll
and that's because we need to explain to
the scroll view what is the size of the
content so the scroll view can compute
how much it has to scroll how can we
give the size of the content we need to
give a size
hint to our stack layout example as a
default it has the same size of the
window so the scroll view thinks that
the content is the size of the window so
it does not scroll so we are going to
change that and here we want to scroll
vertically only so for horizontal i will
keep 100
and for the vertical i'm going to say
none and i'm going to give a value for
example i can give a very big height i'm
going to give
4000 pixel as you hate and let's see
what it gives so you can see that now i
can scroll okay but i'm scrolling too
much because in reality the height of my
content is smaller than four thousand
but it's even worse than that because if
i resize my window this way you can see
that now the height of my content is
more than four thousand so i can still
not see all the content what we are
missing is to get the height of the
content of the stack layout and this
height change when we change the size of
the window in kivy this height is
computed in the stack layout as the
minimum height we can use it by doing
self dot me minimum
height
this value is computed in the stack
layout and it corresponds to the actual
height of the content in the stack
layout let's try it again and you can
see that this time my scroll is correct
and it's just stopping at the end and if
i resize my window i can still scroll to
the end of the content also the scroll
view can work with any kind of layouts
but you have to make sure that you
specify the size so it can scroll
properly and you can choose to scroll
vertically like we did or also to scroll
horizontally that's all that i wanted to
show you with the scroll view let's
continue on the project
we have finished on the scroll view and
we move to the page layout the page
layout makes it possible to go from a
layout to another one just like a book
so we can go from the right to left to
go to the next one or to go back by
sliding on the other side i'm going to
show you that so we are going to create
a page layout example which is a page
layout and it's going to be our main
interface inside we just put a different
layout that are going to be displayed as
a page so for example we first display
the main widget it's not a layout it's a
widget but it's going to work also main
widget and then we can go with our box
layout example and then for example we
can go with the onshore layout example
and then we will put a last one maybe
the grid layout example okay so let's
try this you can see that we get some
kind of weird animation at the start and
i will explain you why we have some
strange display with this page layout so
first we have our main widget with the
hello button and the hello to label okay
and you can see that we have something
on this side that we can just
slide
and then we move to the next one which
is the box layout example but we can
still see that something is displayed on
the background especially if i move it
here that's because the black parts that
you see here it's not black color in
fact it's transparent and because we
don't have any color in the background
of our layouts then it makes some
strange display it's something we are
going to solve when we will see the
canvas section of this project then you
can see i can go back by sliding from
this side or i can move to the next one
and the next one is the onshore layout
so once again all of this part is
transparent so we can still see the
previous layout which is a box the hot
example but i cannot click on them
anymore and then we can move to the next
one so i will show you in this course
how to improve the display of this page
layout by adding some background colors
and also in this course we will see how
to create different screens in our
applications that's not really the case
here here is just a special layout that
takes other layouts inside but i will
show you how to really make different
screen and how to navigate between these
different screens and that's all for the
page layout
let's conclude on the first part of this
project so we saw many examples about
the layouts it may be a lot of
information that we saw here but you
don't need to remember everything what
is the most important is to understand
how works a box layout for example and
then i advise you to practice on your
site to recreate a new project and to
use a box layout to put some elements to
change the size to experiment on your
side it's very important the syntax of
the kv file is the most important also
we learn about the syntax in the python
code it's something that we will use in
some other project but it's something
that is less common that using directly
the kv file and you can see that the
syntax is very efficient and that in a
few lines we can display some content of
course here the content that will
display is not very graphical not very
beautiful but that was not the objective
the objective was to learn how to place
the different content and with all that
layout strategies we will know later how
to create a screen from a graphical
design and that's what we will do inside
this project later when we will create
the menu for example so practice on your
site and also if you want to have more
informations you can type on google tv
layout and you will find this first link
and then you can search in the official
documentation if you want to get more
details or to see more properties like
for example if i go to the box layout
they have some examples in python code
or they have some examples in the kv
file so you may find some extra
informations but all the most important
information is what i already show you
in this section we will continue to
practice with the layouts inside this
project and also in other project but
next we are going to focus on the
widgets because now we only use the
button and the label widget but many
other widgets are available like the
image the slider and so on and that's
what we are going to see in the next
section everything is complete for the
layouts but just before jumping to the
widgets let me show you a practical
example if we look at the mrbits screen
how do you think i have created this
layout in fact this screen is mostly a
combination of box layouts and relative
layouts first we have a vertical box
layout that allows us to stack what i
call the top layout and the bottom
layout the top layout is a relative
layout so we can use the post hint
property to center or to align on the
side on the left we have the logo image
then for the play and stop buttons we
have a box layout centered horizontally
and for the bpm it's a box layout
aligned to the right for the bottom
layout we stack vertically a play
indicator widget it's a widget that we
create in this project and that uses a
horizontal unboxing yield the play
indicator shows where you are currently
playing
and then we have a scroll view it only
scrolls vertically and it includes a
vertical box layout so that we can
insert all the different tracks each
track reject is dynamically built from
the code so that we can easily change
the number of steps that's the buttons
you see here and it will stack them
horizontally with the mrbit project you
will practice your skills both on the
kivy library and on the python language
we will develop some algorithms to
manage the audio part we will create a
real-time audio engine we will mix all
the sounds and all will be perfectly
synchronized at the sample precision we
will also analyze our code and rework it
to optimize the performances of our
program and you will see that it will
make a huge difference i already told
you this project is only available on my
python full course okay let's continue
on our project with the widgets section
let's do it
[Music]
zola project widget version let me show
you a demo of that project you will
learn how to use toggle buttons to
enable or disable other controls then
you will learn how to manage the click
of a button and interact with other
controls here in this label we use a
custom font and then you will learn
about the switch and the slider the
progress bar and also text input after
that i will show you how to add some
image and how to control the display the
objective is to continue learning about
kivy and we are going to practice around
the widget how to manage the click of a
button we are going to learn how to use
new widgets like the toggle button the
switch on the slider and how to display
images i will show you new things about
the kv file syntax like using the
properties and the use of the id
property to connect different controls
we are going to progress with four steps
first step is to implement a counter you
will see how to manage the click of a
button how to use a custom font i will
also show you the toggle button and the
disable state step number two i will
show you the id syntax in the kv file
and you will also learn about the switch
the slider and the progress bar step
number three we will see how to input
some text and step number four we will
display some images let's start with the
step number one
let's start to practice with the widgets
and the first thing you are going to
learn is how to manage the click of a
button so we are going to create a
layout to put our different widgets for
now we are just going to use a button
and a label but when we will click on
the button we will be able to change the
text of the label so let's start and we
are going to call this
widgets
example and we are going to use a grid
layout so it's going to be easy to put
many widgets inside the grid okay let's
say that we have three columns and i
will add a button with a text so i need
to put the semicolon here with the text
click here and we are going to put a
label
with the text
hello and i will change the main
interface with my widgets example let's
try it you see i have my button click
here and i have my text hello now we are
going to see how to manage the click of
the button and at first we are just
going to print a trace here and after i
will show you how to change the text of
the label when we click on the button on
the button you have a property called on
press so we are going to add that on
press and here we can give some python
code so we will call a function here but
first we are going to create that
function for that i will need to define
the class of widgets example so i go
back to my main py and i will create
that class class
with that example it's a grid
layout okay so i can remove this from
the kv file because the class is defined
so shall i define the init function i
don't really need the init function
because we don't want to create some
graphics inside that class we are just
using the kv file for the graphic but we
want to create a function to manage the
click of the button so let's create this
function def and we can use the name
that we want for example on button click
ok inside this function i will just
print
button clicked and i will use this
function name in my kv file on the on
press on the on place i want to say that
i want to call this on button click
function and i need to use a parenthesis
here because it's like python code we
don't give the name of the function we
give the python code that we want to
execute when we click on the button the
on button click function is defined
inside the widgets example inside this
one so should i use self no not really
because self concern the button if i
want to speak about widgets example i
need to use
root okay let's try it and you can see
that if i click on the button i have my
button click trace
that is displayed here okay we can try
multiple times perfect so now let's
change the text of the label when we
click on the button and for this you are
going to use a custom property so let's
say that in the widgets example we have
a property called my text and that is
equal to a string property you need to
import that
import kiwi properties from qv
properties import string property a
string property is working like a string
so we can give a default value for
example hello and i will add an
exclamation sign okay
so now let's say that my text is used by
the label so the label text is going to
be my text and again we need to put
root.mytext we say that we have a
binding that means that the text of the
label will always be the content of my
text property even if my text property
is changed even if you change the
content of my text property it's going
to be automatically linked here and
that's why this kv syntax is very easy
and very powerful if i restart
you can see that now i have hello with
exclamation sign but when i click on my
button i will change my text
so take care because you need to use
self
dot my text if you forget to yourself
it's going to be a local variable and
it's not going to work save my text we
can use it like
we can use it like a standard string i
can do equal to something and i will say
you clicked okay let's try it and you
can see that if i click on my button i
can see you clicked it's as simple as
this
so remember that this is a binding when
i update the content it's going to be
automatically updated on the property of
my control and also remember the on
press property on the button and that
you have to give some python code here
so don't forget to put the parenthesis
that's all for the click of the button
let's continue on the project
for this exercise you are going to
change the code that we have developed
here so that we can count when we click
on the button so at first it will be
displayed one and when you click then it
will be two and then three four five
okay what you need to do is only to
change the code here in the python file
you will not change anything in the kv
file we don't change the graphics here
in your python code you will need to add
a new variable count that you will
initialize to the value 1 when you click
on the button you will increment this
variable and you have to make sure that
you display the content of your int
variable in my text property it's your
time it's your time to practice and
after i will show you the solution
[Music]
first thing to do is to create our
variable so i'm going to create the
count variable that i will initialize to
1. then for the text we are also going
to display one at first when we click on
the button we are going to increment
this variable so for example i can use
count plus equal one and take care you
need to put self to use this variable
okay how can i display the content of
this variable in self my text i can say
it's equal to self dot count how can i
convert a hint to a string i can use the
str
function okay so let's try it you can
see i have one when i click on the
button i still have one so we have a
little bug here but when i click again
it begins to count two three four five
can you see where is the bug in reality
count is equal to one so when i click
for the first time i will still display
one and i will increment the variable
after so i need to increment it
before so it's going to be two and then
i will display two at the first click
let's try it one more time you can see i
have one two three so my counter is
working great i'm just going to change a
little bit text here and i will say
count
ok so everything is complete for this
exercise let's move on to the next
lecture
i am going to show you a few things
about the label and we are going to use
a custom font you have access to the
download link of this resource folder
where you have the fonts directory and
this file
lcd.ttf you will need to copy that
inside your project here in pycharm you
can use the main file and do a right
click and you will see that option
reveal in finder on pc windows it's show
in explorer ok so i will open my folder
reveal in finder and here i will copy
this fonts directory inside my project
ok when it's done you will see this
fonts directory appearing here inside
your project if you are on visual studio
code you just go to the folder of your
project and you copy paste this folder
inside your project folder you will not
see this folder appearing in your
project but if you have copied the files
correctly it's going to work anyway so
now let's use a property on the label to
use this custom font i'm going to use
font
name and the name of the file is lcd.ttf
with an uppercase here but we also need
to give the name of the directory font
so i'm going to write fonts
slash lcd dot ttf okay let's try it you
can see that now my label is displayed a
bit and differently but it's very small
so let's increase the size of the text
font size
and let's say we want something quite
big so 80 dp for example let's try it so
now we have our lcd font displayed on
the label okay and i can still continue
to change the color for example if i
want to use a different color i can say
100 red half green and 100 percent blue
and totally visible okay and it's still
working well that's all that i wanted to
show you about the label and the font
let's continue on the project
i am going to show you how to use a new
widget which is the toggle button the
toggle button is like a button but it
has a state like a switch on and off
let's add this toggle button as the
first element toggle button and we are
just going to put a text that is going
to be toggled so let's see how this
button behaves you can see that from the
display perspective it's exactly like a
button but if i click on it you can see
it has a state it's activated and
deactivated okay and the standard button
is just a click button but it has no
state so how can we manage the state of
the button to manage the state of the
button we are not going to use onpress
but we are going to use on state when
the state of the button changed we are
going to call a function for example
root dot on toggle button states ok and
i will need to create this new function
inside my widget example dev on toggle
button state and i will print toggle
state let's try it you can see that now
when i click on my toggle button i have
this toggle state print that is
displayed okay but how can i get the
state of the button how can i know that
it is activated or deactivated inside
the toggle button there is a property
called state and we want to get that
value inside our function so how can i
get that i'm going to do something that
we are going to use again and again it's
to pass the self argument here i'm going
to pass the toggle button itself in my
function if you go to my function we
have self here but self here is for the
object oriented programming it's
concerning the widget example but the
argument itself
is going to be the toggle button so i
can write toggle button for example or i
can rename it to
widget and you will see that we will
often do that passing the self and
getting the widget here so now i can use
my widget dot state the state is a
string of characters so i can just
display it and let's see what we have so
you can see that when i click on it when
it's activated we have the state down
and when it's deactivated we have the
state normal so it's not activated
deactivated it's normal and down okay so
for example let's change the text of the
button to on and off how can i do that i
can test if
with jet dot state is equal to normal
then it's going to be the off case
else it's going to be the on case how
can i change the text of my button
previously we saw how to do that with a
custom property but look here we already
have the widget so we can use widget
dot text and change the text property to
off directly and i will do the same for
on here if i retry you can see that when
i click on it i have on then off on and
off okay so now i'm going to improve a
little bit my display i want to
initialize directly the text to off and
also to change the size to be 100 dp
reads so let's do that at first i will
display off and i'm going to have a
fixed width of 100 dp so i can use size
hint
and use none
for the width and one for the height 100
percent and for the width i will give
100 dp okay let's try that
it's initialized to off and then on and
then off okay perfect in the next video
we are going to continue to practice on
the toggle button with an exercise
for this exercise you will use the
toggle button on or off to activate or
deactivate the counter in every case it
will be possible to click on the com
button even if it is off but in the case
it's off when you will click on it it
will not increment the counter it should
only be possible to increment it when
the toggle button is on i'll let you
practice on this exercise it's time to
practice on your side
[Music]
when we click on the button we need to
know the state of the toggle button
because if the toggle button is in
normal mode displaying off we should not
increment the count and not update the
text of the label so we can use a new
variable for example count enabled that
is going to be false as a default and
when we click on the toggle button
self dot count enabled is going to be
true and it's going to be false again if
we switch to off false and then only if
count is enabled i will do these lines
so i add a condition if self dot count
if self dot count enabled
then i will increment and i will update
the text let's try it you can see that
as a default it's off i can click on the
button but it's not incrementing now i
activate the counter and now it's
working i can switch it back to off at
any time and on again everything is okay
for this exercise
let's go a little bit further on what we
did previously you can see that you can
see that when the toggle is off we can
still click on the button i am going to
show you how to disable this button so
it's not going to be possible anymore to
click on it when we are in the off state
if i go back to the kv file and if i go
to my button i can use the disabled
property as a default disable is false
that means the button is enabled but if
i put disable to true then in this case
it's no more possible to click on the
button so we are going to change that
disabled state depending on the state of
the toggle button how can we do that we
already have a variable that says if the
count is enabled or not so we want to
use this inside the kv file for this
disabled property to do that i need to
have a property so we can use a boolean
property and we need to import that so
it's kv properties boolean property now
that we have a property we can use it in
the kv file i will take count enabled
and i will use it in the disable here
root dot count enable when the count is
enabled it's going to be true it means
the button is going to be disabled so
that's not what we want to do we will
need to do the opposite when the count
is enabled we want to put false in
disable to enable the button but let's
just try it like this you can see that
in the off state my button is enabled
and in the on state my button is
disabled how can i do the opposite as
this i can use
not
in front of the property to invert the
boolean if it's true it's going to be
false and if it's false it's going to be
true okay if i retry you can see that in
the off state i cannot click on the
button and in the on state i can click
on it and i can count and also you can
use this disabled property on other
widgets that has user interaction that's
all for the disabled property let's move
on to the next lecture
we have completed the step number one
and we move to the step number two let's
continue and i'm going to show you how
to use a new widget the switch the
switch is working a bit like the toggle
button it's going to switch between on
and off it will have a different display
and also it will use in different
properties let's add the switch in our
layout i will write switch and then we
start to see what we have we have our
switch displayed here and we can see we
can change it from on to off okay
perfect now we have a small display
problem here you remember that we gave
100 dp for this button so i will need to
give 100 gp for this switch so that the
column can have a width of 100 db so
let's do that i will copy this size hint
and the width and paste it inside the
switch let's try it okay so this time my
colon is 100 dp and now we want to get
the state of that switch it's not going
to be your own state it's going to be on
active so i will use on active and i
will call a function
on the widget example that we will call
on
switch active and i will create that
function inside the code here at the
bottom def on switch active and because
we pass the self which is the switch
itself we will get this widget parameter
and then i will print the active
property print
switch
plus widget dot active the active
property is a boolean so i will convert
it to a string with str okay let's try
that you can see that if i click on my
switch it's going to be true and then
false so i can get the state of my
switch perfect in the next lecture we
are going to use this switch to enable
or disable some other controls the same
way that we did for the count button
that's all for the switch let's continue
i am going to show you how to use the
slider widget slider widget can be a
horizontal bar to select a value between
a minimum generally 0 and a maximum 100
or it can be also a vertical bar so
let's use the slider i will put it just
after the switch
slider and we are going to give minimum
zero also i need to put semicolon here
okay
maximum 100
these are the default values okay
and let's try it like this so if i
restart here we can see that the slider
is here i will show you how to get the
value but before you can see that at
first the position was totally on the
left so totally on the left means zero
and totally on the right means 100 what
happens if i put a default value
value to 50 for example then you can see
that the position of the slider is on
50. and also i can change the
orientation or orientation to
vertical okay so now let's get the value
of the slider
we can use the
on value and we are going to call a new
function in our class so i will call it
on
slider value and i will pass the slider
here again inside the widgets example
class we are going to go totally at the
bottom and to use def on slider value
self widget
and i will print
slider and we are going to print the
value widget dot
value the value of course is not a
string it's a number so i need to
convert it with str let's try this if i
change the value you can see i get the
value displayed here so it's 0 at the
bottom and it's 100 at the top and we
can also see that it's a float value how
can i convert it to a hint i can use
int here just before the conversion to
the string and then if i restart again
this time i get an int value okay that's
all for now let's continue
for this exercise you are going to add a
label here and to display the value of
the slider so when we will change the
slider you will display the int value of
the slider that we currently print and
you will display it here you will need
to add a label in the kv file and you
will need to use a new property string
property that you will call
slider
value
txt it's your time to practice
[Music]
first thing i will do is to create the
new label label and i will put text
slider value okay if i restart
we can see that we have our label here
and we need to display the value to do
that we are going to create a new
property slider value text
which is going to be equal to default
value of
value for example and we are going to
use that in the label text root dot
slider value text of course i need to
update my slider value text
when we change the value it's on the
slider value i will do self dot slider
value text equal to str int of the
widget value okay let's try it we can
see that if i change the slider i can
see the value of my slider that was the
objective of the exercise but now i'm
going to go further and i'm going to
show you a new syntax that is more
efficient and that will avoid using this
new property so i will just go backward
and comment this also comment this slide
and i will use a fixed value in my label
for example value okay i start again and
you can see that value is displayed and
it's no more working ok i am going to
use something new it's called id id
makes it possible to use a kind of
variable inside the kv file and i will
say that slider is my
slider then i can directly use my slider
inside the text property of the label
and i can say that i want to bind my
slider dot value and of course i need to
convert it to a string as simple as this
let's try it and you can see that i can
change the value of my slider and i can
see the value here of course i can
convert it to hint if i want it's going
to work okay let's try again okay it's
working fine and also you can see that
we don't need anymore the on value here
i will just comment it we are just using
it for the print but i'm going to
comment it and you can see that it is
still working perfect so what we did is
to use id and to put a name you can put
the name that you want here like a
variable and inside my label when i do
this we do a binding so automatically
when the value of my slider is changing
the text of the label will be updated
that's a very simple and very efficient
syntax
that's all for this exercise
you are now going to use the switch to
enable or disable the slider and you are
going to do this only in the kv file for
this exercise i don't want any
modifications in the python file you
will need to use id syntax like we did
previously you will need to use disable
property and also to use active property
of the switch also i want the switch to
be activated as a default when we start
the program it's your time to practice
[Music]
i want to enable or disable the slider
so i will use the disabled property we
need to put something here what do we
need to put we need to put something
depending on the active property of the
switch you remember that we use
previously this active property which is
a boolean and so i will need to use an
id on the switch
my switch for example okay so here in
the slider disabled i will use my switch
dot active if the switch is active it
will be true so it means disable is true
that means the slider will be disabled
that's not what we want so we will do
not before to have the opposite let's
try that okay
you can see that the switch is off i
cannot use the slider it's disabled when
the switch is on i can use it perfect so
now i want the switch to be on the on
position as as a default so we are going
to use active
and put it to true and because it's a
binding when i will start the program
the slider is going to be also activated
that's all for this exercise
i will show you how to display and use a
progress bar and this progress bar we
are going to link it to the value of the
slider so i want to display it just
under the label how we can do that we
can stack the label and the progress bar
inside a box layout and this box layout
is going to be vertical so i will use
orientation vertical okay below the
label i'm going to add a progress
bar
for now i don't use any properties let's
have a look okay you can see my progress
bar is displayed here for now it's just
a line but if i use some properties like
for example the maximum value to 100 the
minimum value in the progress bar is
always zero you cannot customize it okay
but for the max i give 100 and for
example i can use value and give 25 so
if i start you can see that the progress
bar is at 25 percent now i want to use
the value of the slider to be displayed
in the progress bar how can i do that i
can just copy
my slider dot value and paste that in
the value of the progress bar let's try
it now you can see that we start at 50
and that the value is changing with the
slider and that's all for the progress
bar
we have completed step number two we go
to step number three text input
we are going to use the text input so
that the user can input some text in the
interface and we are going to use that
just below the box layout i will write
text input okay and we are going to
start it just like this so we can see
this box here where i can enter some
text and because we want to keep this
column of 100 dp i'm going to resize my
text input i will copy size hint and the
reads just here ok so i have my text
input here and you can see i can type
some text i will show you how to put a
default text and also how to get the
text and display it on a label so let's
do that for example the default text is
going to be fu so if i restart you can
see that the default text is displayed
here and i can also change it okay
and when i press enter i can change the
lines so it's a multiple line as a
default i will show you later how to
change that but first let's use a label
so here i will add a label how can i
display the text of my text input inside
my label i will use text
and here i will use an id my text input
and i will use this id my text input not
text
and if i do that you see that i have a
binding that means i display foo and
when i change the text input it's
automatically updated even if i use
multiple lines perfect now let's say
that we want to change the behavior and
that we want to use only one line in the
text input but i will update and i will
also update the label only when i will
press enter here to confirm the line so
let's do that i can use the property
multiline and set it to false as a
default the text input is multi-line if
i do this you can see that now if i
change the content here and if i press
enter the color is changing a little bit
i don't go to a next line but the text
has been validated but i want to change
a bit this behavior because you can see
that when i update the text the label is
automatically updated i want to update
the label only when i will press enter
for this we are going to use on text
validate
this on text validate and we are going
to define a new function that is going
to be called only when we validate the
text that means when we press enter on
the line root dot on text validate and i
will give the text input with the self
and i will create this new function at
the end of the widget example class and
f on text validate with widget okay i am
going to change this binding so i'm
going to remove that and we are going to
create a new string property in the code
so i will copy paste that and i will
call it text
input str as a default we are going to
put foo
okay
text input str is what i'm going to
display in my label so i'm going to
write root dot text input str okay
so now text input str i'm going to
update it only when i validate my text
when i press enter so here i will have
self
text input str is going to take the new
text of the widget equal widget dot
equal widget dot text okay let's try it
so now you can see i have full if i
update some content here it's not
updating the label but if i press enter
it's updated and also what we can do is
for example in the text i can add
another string here i can concatenate
with a string and i can say
your name is okay so if i do that your
name is fu if i write brian enter your
name is brian that's all for the text
input
we have completed the step number three
and we move to the images first thing
you will copy the image folder to your
project like we did previously you will
find that folder inside the resource
folder that you have downloaded when
it's complete you will see image folder
appearing inside your project we are
going to start with a new example
because previously we have added many
things inside the screen so i want to go
back from an empty screen we are going
to create a new example
image
example and it's going to be a great
layout i'm going to reuse the same thing
with three columns and it's going to be
my main interface so if i restart and we
have an empty screen okay inside i will
add an image and to select the image
file you will use the source property we
are going to display the cake you will
first need to put the folder name
slash
cake dot jpeg okay let's start this you
can see that the cake is displayed if i
resize the window the image is resized
and you can also see that the ratio
aspect of the image is preserved so if i
reduce the width it's reduced and also
if i reduce the height it's also resized
but you can see that when i expand the
window it's going to be resized of its
original size in the file it's not going
to expand i am going to show you how to
do that by using some new properties so
first let's copy this image three times
okay so we have something like this and
i'm going to use a new property and that
is
hello
stretch
and i'm going to give true okay let's
see what happens
you can see that the second image is now
able to straight that means to expand to
a bigger size than the original size and
why it's not stretching to the first
image it's because the three elements
have the same size here so it's actually
expanding to the size that the layout
give to the image okay let's continue
with some other properties and i'm going
to show you how to use keep
ratio
as a default keep ratio is true now we
are going to give false to say that we
don't need to keep the aspect ratio of
that image and we apply this to the
third image if i restart you can see
that strangely it's no effect on that
image and that's because this property
can only be used with a low straight so
you need to specify a low stretch to
true and also combine it with the keep
ratio to false and let's retry and this
time you can see that the ratio is not
preserved but the image will take all
the allocated space so it's not really
rendering well for that kind of image
but it's going to be useful for
background image like gradients if you
look at the files here you see we have
this jpeg file and we have also png
files and that we will use later in this
project the difference between png and
jpeg is that png can have transparency
jpeg cannot have transparency but it can
compress better than the png and that's
all concerning the images
that's all for the widgets you might ask
me is it possible to create an
application with multiple screens and
how can we go from one screen to another
yes it's possible and that's what we
call the navigation
in qv there is a class named the screen
manager you can search on google for
screen manager tv and you will find some
examples in my python full course i will
cover the navigation you will learn how
to create multiple screens how to manage
navigation stack so you can push new
screens and also pop to go back to the
previous screen we will also use the
action bar and all of this works for
every platforms including ios and
android okay let's go back to our
project and we move to the canvas
section you will learn how to draw lines
and shapes on the screen let's do it
[Music]
the la project canvas version let me
show you a demonstration of that project
you can see a new button here canvas and
we can access to all the canvas examples
that we are going to create together
canvas makes it possible to draw some
shapes on the screen for example here an
ellipse rectangle and also a spring that
can adapt to the window widths you will
see how to center items how to change
the colors and also how to move some
shapes on the screen the objective is to
learn how to display graphical
instructions on the screen like a line
rectangles circles and so on you will
understand the interaction of the canvas
with the widgets you will see how to
move instructions on the screen like we
will do for the ball and also you will
see how to call a function at a regular
interval of time we will create an
update function that we will call 60
times per second concerning the
instructions you will learn how to draw
a rectangle by giving a position and a
size same for the ellipse position and
size and also you will learn how to use
the line instructions to draw lines from
multiple points and also to draw
rectangle and to draw ellipse then you
will see the color instruction and give
the three components red green blue we
are going to add instructions in the kv
file but also in the code concerning the
kv file you have a sample here you can
see that we add the graphical
instructions inside a canvas and the
canvas is inside a widget it can be any
widget like a layout or it can be a
button what is important is to remember
that the instructions is like a list the
order of the instructions are important
for example here we have a red color and
here we have a blue color on the screen
you can see that the circle and the
ellipse are red but the rectangle is
blue here i have the width which is
here the circle is drawn at 200 x and
200 y
and 100 radius the width is the
thickness of the line in the code it's
going to be the same principle but the
syntax is different for example here we
are going to draw an ellipse at a
position and the size and what is
important is that we can
remember the instruction inside a
variable here the ball variable and it's
possible to update the instruction for
example here we can update the position
of the instruction so at the start the
ball is drawn at 100 100 but then by
just changing the position property on
the ball the ball is going to move at
200 100
we don't need to call again ellipse
ellipse is already in the screen but the
instruction automatically knows that it
needs to be redrawn when we change the
properties we are going to go forward in
multiple steps first step i'm going to
show you how to use the instructions in
the kv file like the rectangle the
ellipse the line and the color then we
are going to do that inside the code
then i will show you how to do movement
like the poll and i will explain you the
coordinates system we will see the
exception with the relative layout and
finally we will improve the page layout
by adding backgrounds to the different
pages and also we will create the menu
for the different canvas examples are
you ready to start let's do it
okay let's start with the canvas section
first thing we will do is to define a
canvas example number one so in your
main.py you will add a new class
class canvas
example1 and it's going to be a widget
ok and i will add pass inside this class
in the kv file you are going to create
this example canvas
example
one okay and inside i will do tab canvas
semicolon and i will define this new
canvas example as the main interface
okay so take care because this first
line here is very important that is what
we call the main interface so when we
will do some other examples like canvas
example 2 canvas example 3 you will need
to replace it on this first line here to
change your main interface okay now have
a look because for the remaining of this
tutorial the list of files is going to
be different it's because the videos are
extracted from my full python course
however i did not include the navigation
part in these tutorials so the list of
files is going to be different but it
will be very simple because instead of
working in canvas example.kv
and
canvasexample.py you will always work in
the main.py and the lab.kv so for
example here in
canvasexample.kv you will not create new
file you will not create this file but
you will do this in your thelab.kv file
just like we did previously and for the
canvas example.py also you will not
create this file and you will not use
vsi but you will just put your class
inside your main.py let's continue and
you can see that canvas example1 is a
widget that means that for every widget
or every layout it's possible to add a
canvas section even inside the button a
button is a widget so we can add canvas
inside a button if you want inside
canvas you are going to write the
graphical instructions for example
rectangle if we start this
you can see a white rectangle on the
lower left of your screen as a default
the color is white and also as a default
the size is 100 pixels per 100 pixels we
can change the position and the size by
using
post property and here i will put the
position in dp dp of 100 ndp of 200 for
the y and for the size i can give dp 150
and also ndp 150 to get a square so
let's try it
okay we have our rectangle here 100 dp
200 dp and 150 for the size of course we
can use pixels directly and sometimes in
the examples i will use only pixels but
as a good practice use always in dp but
as a good practice use always in dp in
your programs also take care because the
syntax inside the canvas is different
than the syntax directly inside the
widget let's continue how can i display
my rectangle at the center of the screen
i can change the position and use self
dot center but you can see that if i do
that in fact my rectangle is not
centered because the position
corresponds to the lower left point so i
will need to subtract the half of the
width and the half of the height so
let's do that but before i want to show
you something new it's possible in the
kv file to define some variables and the
syntax is hash semicolon set and then
the name of the variable for us it's
going to be the size so we can say s
and we give the value dp of 150 so here
i can replace by s
and s so if i restart you can see we
still have the same thing concerning the
center i can use center x and self dot
center y still i will have
the same thing here but now it's going
to be easy to subtract the values x i'm
going to subtract the half s divided by
2 and the same for the y let's try it
you can see that this time my square is
centered in the window and because you
are in the kv file its bindings so when
i resize the window
my position is automatically updated i
show you another instruction which is
the ellipse with the ellipse you can
draw circle or ellipse and it's working
the same way you give the position and
also the size for the position for
example i will give 200 pixels and 500
for the y and for the size i can give
for the width s and for the height s
divided by two let's try it you can see
the ellipse is displayed here that's all
for this first part let's continue
i am going to show you how to draw lines
with the line instruction the line
instruction use different properties we
are going to define some points with
points and it's going to be a tuple of x
and y and x2 y2 to define the different
points so let's start from 0 to 0 and go
to second point which is located to x
equal 100 and y equal 100 let's try this
you see that we have a line here
starting from 0 0 lower left and going
to 100 100 but then we can add some
other points for example i can write 200
0. so we have here another segment
located at 200 okay
and we can also say we want to go to the
width of the window self not reads to be
totally on the right and go at 100 okay
let's try that you can see that we have
a last segment that will depend on the
window width we can go further in this
example and draw a spring that will
adapt on the window widths let's do that
for example i'm going to create points
at every quarter of the window so i will
use self width divided by 4 and go to
100
then i will have
self width divided by 2 going to 0 then
self width multiply by 3 divided by 4
and go to 100 and finally width going to
0 let's try it and you can see we have
the spring that adapts to the window
width perfect we can also use another
property to change the width of the line
and i can use here grids and i can say
two and you can see that the line is
thicker that's all for this example
concerning the line
let's do an exercise first we are going
to create the canvas example 2 so we are
going to define this in the kv file with
canvas inside ok in the python file we
are going to create canvas example two
okay let's start the program you can see
that we have an empty screen for this
exercise you will need to draw a cross
you will have a vertical line centered
in the screen and you will have a
horizontal line centered in the screen
and of course if you resize the window
it has to adapt always to the center of
the screen it's time to practice on your
side
inside canvas example.kv i'm going to
write the lines instruction first line
is going to be for example the
horizontal line so i'm going to give the
points and we are going to start on the
left of the window for the x i'm going
to have 0 and for the y i'm going to
have self dot heights
divided by 2. to get the point on the
right i use self dot
width and also height divided by two
okay and we can keep the width to two so
the line is more visible let's try that
you can see we have the horizontal line
and when i resize the window it's always
centered vertically perfect let's add
the vertical line i'm going to copy this
instruction i will delete all the points
for the vertical line i start in the
middle of the screen so it's going to be
self dot reads divided by two if we
start from the bottom y is going to be
equal to zero then we go to several
tweets divided by two and to the point
totally at the top of the screen self
dot 8
so we have the vertical line and the
horizontal line we have the cross that's
all for the exercise
we continue on the examples you are
going to create canvas example number
three and i'm going to show you how to
draw a rectangle circle and ellipse by
using the line previously we already saw
how to draw rectangle and ellipse but it
was filled of colors now we are going to
draw only the line so let's create a
canvas example tree and i will go to the
python file to create example number
three inside canvas example tree i will
write canvas and then i will use the
line instruction in the line instruction
we are not going to use the points but
we are going to use new properties like
circle circle is a tuple and you will
give center x
center y
and the radius for example i give 200
and 200 for the position and 100 for the
radius and i can use the width property
let's try that so you can see i have the
circle here and i can continue with an
ellipse so i will copy that
for the ellipse
it's almost the same but it's going to
be radius x and radius y
so here for example you are going to
change the position to
500 and 300
and for the radius let's say 100 for the
x and 200 for the y and for example we
can change the width let's try that
we can see the ellipse here okay 100
radius for the x and 200 for the y and
also i can draw a rectangle for the
rectangle it's going to be the x y
width and height
so let's try 800 and 100 for the
position and for the size 300 width and
208 okay i will keep with
two let's try that
and we have a rectangle just here
perfect now i want to show you how to
use the colors color is an instruction i
can add my color here inside the canvas
color and i will specify air gb
red green blue
if you want a red color we will give 100
red 0 and 0 for the blue okay if i start
this
you can see that all the shapes are red
and that's because we change the color
here and all the graphical instructions
after the coloring section that's
because the color instructions was
before all the other graphical
instructions but if i move this one just
after the circle then you can see that
the circle is white default color and
only the ellipse and the rectangle are
red okay i will put it back at the
beginning and i will show you something
more i can use also rgb a with alpha
component as a default it's 100
visible but i can use for example 30
and we have something like this also if
i want to change only the color of the
rectangle i can use another color
instruction and let's say that we want
to display the rectangle in blue so i
will use 0 for red and 100 blue and also
100
visible okay so this time the rectangle
is blue previously we use color as a
property on the widget but inside the
canva color is an instruction it's not a
property that you will apply to your
circle or your ellipse directly it's a
global color property and all the other
graphical instructions after it will
take this color that's all for this
example let's continue
i'm going to show you how to use the
canvas inside the python code we are
going to create a new example canvas
example four okay why do we want to use
the canvas inside the code for example
in some cases you will want to use a
loop to display many shapes in the
canvas i am going to show you how to use
it and we are going to do similar
instructions that we did previously
inside the kv file we are going to
create the init function f init and we
are going to call super
super init with
kw args
okay
if you want to use the canvas you write
with
safe canvas and you write the canvas
instructions inside this code block for
example line instruction with points
property and we give the tuple of points
100 for x and y of the first point and
400 500 for the second point also you
need to import the line instruction
kv-graphics vertex instruction ok let's
try that
you can see we have the line here and
also it's possible to add other
properties like the widths equal to okay
let's try this we have width equal to
perfect i can also continue and use a
color instruction color here i will use
a green color 0 red 100 grid and 0 blue
you need to import color from kv
graphics
this one okay and i'm going to draw a
circle line you remember that for circle
we need to use center x for example 400
200 and the radius 80 and i'm going to
keep reads equal to okay let's try this
here i have an error because circle is a
property so you need to use circle equal
the tuple with information let's try
again okay i have the circle here in
green perfect and we can continue we can
draw a rectangle the same way that we
did previously rectangle it's really the
equivalent that we did here if you look
at circle it's the same name of the
property and it's the same logic
concerning the different values for the
rectangle it's going to be the same x y
width and height
so for example 700 for the x
500 for the y and 150 widths and 100
height and we can change the width for
example to five and i get a rectangle
here okay if we want to draw a rectangle
filled with some colors we need to use
the rectangle
instruction like we did in the kv file
at the beginning and we have to give
both and size properties so i will give
both equal
the position for example 700 and 200
and size property equal 150 100 and you
need to import
rectangle okay let's try that you can
see the field rectangle displayed here
that's all for this first part
concerning the use of the canvas inside
the code
we are able to draw some instructions on
the screen now i will show you how to
update the instructions to move them and
for example we are going to move this
rectangle on the right so let's do that
we will add a button on the interface
and every time we will click on that
button the rectangle will move from 10
db on the right first thing we are going
to do is to add the button in the
interface i will define the canvas
example in the kv file canvas example 4
and i will add a button position for
example 100 and 400 and for the text
i will say a okay let's try that so now
we have a button on the interface and we
will need to manage the click of the
button by using the on press property we
have to create a new function in canvas
example four for example on
button a click ok
so let's create this function i go back
to the python file inside canvas example
four i'm going to write dev on button a
click let's just see if it works so i'm
going to add a print
foo okay let's try that and you can see
that if i click on the button we have
foo appearing here so the click of the
button is working let's continue now i
want to update the position of this
rectangle to do this we need to remember
the instruction inside a variable for
example wrecked variable and it's going
to be an instance variable so i can use
it in another function here on the
button click to update the instruction i
have to update the properties on it here
it's the position so i will write
self.track.pos
equal something it needs to be a tuple
with x and y and for our first example i
will put 100
100. let's try that you see that if i
click on the button the rectangle moves
to the 100 and 100 position when you
update properties on instructions the
canva detects that he has to redraw the
instruction let's improve that so we can
move the rectangle on the right with x
and y i can do this get the x and y from
the current position and i want to
update the value of the x x plus equal
for example
10 db and you need to import dp from the
matrix okay and now i will build a new
tuple with x and y of course it's not
possible to do something like this to
access to the first item of the tuple
and to increment it why because the
tuple is immutable you cannot change the
tuple so the only way to do this is to
assign the property a new tuple here i
will give same value of the y but i will
update the x to be 10 db more on the
right so let's try this when i click on
the button you see the rectangle is
moving and i can click again and again
that's all for this step
we are able to move the rectangle on the
side but you can see that the rectangle
can also go out of the window and we
want to avoid that we want that at most
it's going to be aligned to the right of
the screen and that's what you are going
to do as an exercise
[Music]
i'm going to add some variables here we
are going to add w for the width and the
height of the rectangle and it's going
to be right dot size okay also i will
add an increment variable that is as a
default dp of 10 and that we will use to
change the x value and you will need to
add a condition to modify the content of
this variable so sometimes it's only 5dp
if you have only 5dp remaining on the
right and it will be 0dp if you are
already aligned on the right for the
computation you will use self dot reads
which is the reads of the window and you
will use also x which is the left part
of the rectangle
and w which is the width of the
rectangle so for the right border of the
rectangle it's x plus w it's time for
you to practice on this exercise i will
compute the remaining space with a new
variable diff so diff is going to be
safe not to it
minus the position of the right border
the position of the right border is x
plus w
so let's write this diff equal self dot
width
minus
x plus w
the right position of the border and the
window width okay if
div
is less
than what we want to increment so it
means we don't have much space left we
are just going to increment by what we
have remaining and maybe it's already
zero so in the case this is zero we are
not going to move our position it means
we are already on the right but if we
have only five dp remaining we are just
going to move to five more dp to be
aligned on the right of the window and
if we have enough space we will not go
inside this condition and we will move
of 10 db let's try this you can see that
the rectangle can move and when it
reaches the right of the window it just
stay here okay if i resize the window
it's going to work because self.width is
updated okay and if i get a smaller
window and if i click on the button we
will compute also the right position and
that's all for this exercise
we saw how to move a rectangle by
objecting the position property and now
i'm going to show you how to move a
shape automatically we are going to call
a function with a time interval in this
new example canvas example
5 we are going to draw a ball that will
move in the screen and that will rebound
on the borders canvas example 5 i'm
going to take the first lines of the
canvas example 4 with the init function
and
with canvas ok we are going to draw the
ball to draw the ball we use ellipse and
we use the position for example 100 100
and also the size for example
50 dp and
50db perfect
you need to import ellipse here
okay so if i start this
we can see the ball on the screen
i am going to improve the code here i
want to define a variable that will be
the size of the ball so i will write
self dot ball
size equal
dp 50 perfect and i will replace this
inside my code self ball size now i want
to display my ball in the center of the
window i can use position equal
self dot center but you can see that if
i use this it's not going to work and
that's because in the init function we
don't have the size of the window
already it's too early in the
initialization of the graphics so as a
default the window size is only 100 per
100 pixels at that time so we get only
50 and 50 position here and if i resize
the window it's not going to change
because it's not a binding here it's not
like in the kv file it's not going to
update automatically it's just a line of
code and it has been executed only one
time in the init function so we will
need to use another function and there
is a function that is called on size and
that it is called when we change the
size of the window so i will write this
def
on size and it use arg
ok and we are going to add a print to
print the size of the window on size
and i will add width str of self
dot reads
and
the height
str
7.8 okay let's try that you can see that
when we started the program we get on
size with the right size of the window
because on size is called later after
the init and when i change the size of
the window we get the print that is
called with the new size of the window
so how can i update my code to make the
ball displayed at the center of the
window i can use an instance variable
self dot
ball and i will update the position of
the ball when we change the size of the
window
self.ball dot position
equal self dot center let's try this you
can see it is working but that the ball
is not totally in the center of the
window because the position is the
lowest left point so we will need to
subtract the half of the size of the
ball so let's do that ball position is a
tuple with self center x and self center
y and we are going to subtract self ball
size divided by 2 and do the same for
the y and if i restart this you can see
that the ball is totally centered
now how can i move the ball we are going
to use something new to call a function
regularly with an amount of time at the
end of the init function we are going to
add a new line clock dot schedule
interval and we will need to create a
new function that we will call update
function
self.update and we give the time
interval if i put one it's going to be
called every one second you need to
import clock take care here it's not kv
clock it's kv properties clock from kv
dot properties import clock okay and we
need to create the new function def
update you can use the name that you
want for this function but take care
because every function call with
schedule needs to have a parameter which
is dt
delta time i will explain you how to use
this parameter in the galaxy project
here i will add a print and i will say
update if i start the program
you can see that the print update is
called every second how can i speed up
this i can say for example
0.5 so it's going to be called every
half second or two times per second if i
restart you can see that it is more
frequent here so let's change the
position of the ball in this update
function
self ball position
equal so i have x and y here and i will
say
x plus 10 and y okay if i restart you
can see the ball is changing but this is
quite slow so how can we update that
that's because we call it only two times
per second and you know that for games
we usually refresh 60 times per second
60 frames per second so here i will
write 1 divided by 60 and i have my ball
moving quite quickly also you can change
the speed of the ball by changing the
amount that you increment every time for
example 4 and you see the ball is moving
in the screen that's all for this step
the ball can move but now we want that
the ball does not goes out of the window
that the ball can rebound and that's
what we are going to do here the ball is
going to move on the x and on the y and
has to rebound on the four sides of the
screen but first i'm going to define the
speed of the ball self.velocity
x
equal
3dp and for the y
it's going to be
4dp and of course every time we call the
update function here i will remove the
plus 4. the x
will be plus equal to
v self.vx and the y plus equal to
self dot v y and you can see that this
time
the ball is moving on the x and the y
axis perfect
for this exercise you will need to add
some conditions and you will need to
test if the ball is going out of the
window remember that x and y are the
lower left part of the ball if you want
to get the right part and the top part
of the ball you will need to use the
self dot ball
size and you will need to test with self
reads the width of the window and self
hate the height of the window when you
want to rebound we are going to say that
the speed is going to be the opposite
okay so for example if your ball goes
out of the screen on the right you are
going to invert the speed so that every
time you go to the update function you
are going to increment with something
negative so you will go to the left side
and you are going to do the same
principle with the v y it's your time to
practice on this exercise
[Music]
if i start the program you can see that
first and the ball goes out of the
screen on the top so we are going to add
this first condition if
the y of the ball and i want to get the
top of the ball so it's y plus
self ball size
it's greater than the height of the
window 7.8
then we are going to go on the other
direction self dot v y equal minus
seven v y also the maximum value of the
y for the ball is going to be self dot
height
minus the ball size so if you are above
this value i just put the limit on the y
and we go to the other side and we
rebound let's try this you can see that
the ball rebounds and then goes out of
the screen on the right so i will add
this condition if x
plus the right part of the ball so x
plus ball size is greater than self dot
width then again the maximum value for
the x is several tweets minus
the ball size and i'm going to invert
the v x
okay let's try this
so now we rebound on the top and we
rebound on the right we need to add the
two more conditions for the bottom if
y is less than zero then y equal 0 and
we rebound on the y axis same thing for
the x
if x is less than 0 then x equals 0 and
we rebound on the x axis let's try that
okay we rebound also on the bottom again
on the top and on the left and if i
resize my window we kept the ball
position equal center of the window but
if i release it's moving again
everything is complete for this exercise
we are going to create a new example
canvas example 6
and i'm going to do some experiments
with the coordinates of the canvas and
also using the canvas with some other
widgets that we use previously like the
button and we are also going to use the
relative layout so let's do that canvas
example 6 pass
and then i go to the kv file and i
create canvas example 6. we are going to
start with a button so i will write
button with text
a ok i start and i have a button on the
lower left of the window button is a
widget so i can add a canvas inside my
button canvas and i will display a
rectangle if we try this
we can see that the rectangle is
displayed on top of the button and that
the rectangle is displayed at the
coordinate 0 0. this is because the
order of the instructions matters first
the button has been drawn and after we
have added the instruction of the
rectangle we can change the order of the
instructions i can use canvas
b4 to move this instruction before the
instructions of the button in that case
the button is displayed on top of the
rectangle and also you have canvas dot
after i will go back with canvas if i
move the button with position for
example position 100
100 you can see that only the button
moved and not the rectangle however the
rectangle is inside the canvas of the
button but you need to understand
something important here the canvas is
always drawn at position 0 0 always it's
going to be one exception with a
relative layout and i'm going to show
you that but first you can see that this
is not related to the button if i use a
box layout for example i will comment
this property you can see that the
canvas of the box iot even if we change
the position to 100 100 is always at
zero zero the only difference will be
for the
relative layout in that case you can see
that the rectangle moved and actually
it's not exactly what you think the
canvas position is still at 0 0 but the
relative layout moved the canvas space
to its position the relative layout is
the only exception that does this i show
you another example if here i use a box
layout and i add two button button with
text
a and button with text b if i restart
you can see that strangely the box
layout has a small size here of 100 per
100 that's because canvas example is a
widget it's not a layout a widget does
not takes care about the position or the
size of the children so he will give a
default size for the box i would which
is 100 per 100 if you want to occupy all
the window widths we have to do
explicitly size equal to the root dot
size in the previous layout examples
that we did we did not have to do that
because it was directly a layout and it
was not a layout inside a widget okay
but here if i take the size of the
widget explicitly my box layout takes
all the size of the window perfect now i
want to draw a rectangle instead of the
a button i can use an empty widget if i
replace button by widget i have an empty
widget here and i can use a canvas on
this widget canvas and i will draw a
rectangle okay let's try it we have the
rectangle at 0 0 in the canvas and i can
use size
on the rectangle to get the size of the
widget
self dot size take care it's not root
note size because root is canvas example
six
root size will be all the size of the
window but we want to use only self.size
because we want to use only the size of
this widget if i restart you see that we
have a white rectangle and i can change
the color by using a color instruction
inside the canvas rgb for example green
color zero one zero okay i have a green
rectangle how can i do the same for the
b button i want to draw a blue rectangle
i'm going to copy all this section and
replace button by a widget
with a rectangle that is
blue and you will see that this time the
blue rectangle is displayed on the left
because the canvas always starts at 0
zero so if you want to move the
rectangle we need to give a position to
the rectangle and we are going to give
self.position to get the position of the
widget
this time it's working i have the green
rectangle on the left and the blue
rectangle on the right also we can do
the same thing with a relative layout
for example if i replace widget by
relative
layout i can remove the position here
because the relative layout will move
its canvas to its position you can see
that the blue rectangle is still here
it's drawn at 0 0 but because of the
relative layout it moved to its position
that's all that i wanted to show you
concerning the coordinates and the
relative layout
for this exercise i'm going to ask you
to draw 3 rectangle blue white and red
like the french flag you will create a
new example canvas example 7 but this
example is going to be directly a box
layout and not a widget so i will write
box layout here canvas example 7 take
care because you need to import box
layout ok so you will do this exercise
remember that for the white color you
need to use one one and one it's your
time to practice
[Music]
okay i will add the first rectangle i
will copy this relative layout that i
will put in the box layout and it's blue
then i will use a
white one with one and one also you can
see that if i add only this one it's
going to take all the space of the
window automatically because we start
with a box layout and not with a widget
okay then i add the white one and also
the red one everything is okay for this
exercise
you have completed the lab project
congratulations you are now able to
create user interfaces in python with
the tv library but let's go a bit
further with kivy by creating a
real-world project
part number two the galaxy project
version one
let's start
[Music]
welcome to the galaxy project it is an
advanced project that means you had to
follow the previous video of this course
and also be able to do all the exercise
if that's not the case practice a little
bit more and when you are ready you can
start on this project what is galaxy
it's a game in three dimension or in
perspective mode and the player has to
move the spaceship on the left and on
the right to stay on the track if you go
out of the track you will have a game
over let me show you a demo of the
project
so you can see we have a menu we have
also sound that says galaxy and when i
press start
the game is starting with some
background music
i can go on the left on the right and
follow the land i also have the score
which is updated
and if i go out of the track
i go into the game over and i can also
restart the program
again and again the objectives of the
project is to create a desktop windows
linux or mac os or mobile game ios and
android
from a to z you will practice on apps
development with kivy especially on the
canvas you will learn how to structure
your code and to organize it you will
improve your debugging skills especially
on the errors but also when we want to
improve some behaviors of the game so
you will need to do some investigation
we will need to create some algorithm so
you will practice on the land generation
but also on the perspective display you
will also need to create and implement
all the game elements like the land and
the ship and you will code all the game
logic user actions what we have to do
when the user press left when the user
goes out of the track you will display
the score and trigger the different
sounds at the right moment we will
progress on three steps first version
you will display the grid in two
dimensions and then you will transform
the display to display it in perspective
and finally we will also add the
movement to go forward into the level
and also to be able to go on the left
and on the right step number two we will
generate the land i mean the track that
we have to follow we will also display
the ship and we will manage the
collisions that mean we will observe if
the ship is still on the track or if it
is out of the track and in that case we
will just print game over on the v3 we
will finalize our project to display the
menu trigger the different sounds
display the background image and manage
the score why did i choose to create
this game i did not want it to create
another pong or a flappy bird or a
classic snake i wanted to create
something new i started from this
concept of a car game in two-dimension
with a land generation and i like this
idea to practice on the land generation
algorithm so i kept this id but i was
thinking of something using a grid so we
can have different algorithm concerning
the land but then i also thought about
the visual aspect and i was thinking why
not transforming this 2d aspect to a
perspective mode then i change my
concept of the car to a spaceship and
have something in the space and have a
kind of different levels where you need
to reach a planet something like that so
this choice is to avoid the classics
like the pongs the snakes to have this
learned generation algorithm which is
very interesting to learn and to
practice on to have an interesting
visual aspect and also i don't mean that
i created a new game concept it's other
games like this that already exist but i
never saw any existing tutorials about
it so it's something new and exclusive
that you will learn into that course how
does it works in fact we are going to
work in a 2d mode with a grid and then
we are going to transform that into a
perspective mode we will implement this
function later transform perspective do
you need to be good at math to do this
in fact not really i simplified
everything so you just need to
understand the compute of proportions
for example if i tell you that one us
dollar equals 90 of euro
how much is one euro in us dollar in
that case is 1 divided by 0.9 1.111
if you understand this concept you can
follow the mathematics behind the
perspective transform else if you really
cannot follow mathematic concepts you
will be able to follow these tutorials
in 2d mode because all of the logic of
the game is done in 2d and the
perspective is only to change the
coordinates for the display how does we
have this movement of going forward into
the game in reality we are just going to
offset the grid vertically so for
example if we start with this grid i put
two lines in color we will shift it
downstairs so we have this impression to
go forward into the game again and again
and when we will reach this point at the
base we will just loop to go back at the
initial position so that we have this
illusion that the game is always going
forward i will explain you that in more
details later concerning the ship
movement on the left and on the right in
fact the ship will be always displayed
in the center of the screen and for
example if the user press the right key
we are going to move the land on the
left so that we have this illusion that
the ship moves on the right and this
principle is going to work also when we
press on the left concerning the land
generation i have prepared a simple
algorithm you will be able to go forward
to go on the right or to go on the left
and it's going to be random so we will
have three patterns just going forward
going on the right and going on the left
so that we can generate a random and
also infinite because when we go forward
into the game we have some part of the
pass that will go out of the screen so
we will recycle it to generate new
elements at the top and this is going to
be displayed perfectly in perspective so
that the player will have to move on the
left and on the right to stay on the
track we are going to start right now
with the v1 you are going to create the
project to define the coordinates of the
perspective point to generate the grid
with the vertical and horizontal lines
we will also create the transformation
of the coordinates that we can go from
the 2d grid to the perspective mode
finally we will also implement the
forward movement and also the movement
on the left and on the right when the
user press the keyboard keys on computer
or press the screen on mobile are you
ready to start let's do it
let's create our new project i put the
name galaxy and i will use the same
options as usual i will click on the
create button when it's ready we will
add the new python file main and i will
begin to write some code
class
galaxy app
coming from the app class and i will put
nothing inside i need to import
the
tv.app not app okay and i will add my
main widget
class
main widget coming from widget and i
will put pass inside and import this
import kv uix widget
ok and of course i need to instantiate
my application so i need to use
parenthesis dot run okay and i will also
add my kv file so i need to add not in
the vf but put it here new
file galaxy dot kv with the same name as
app without app okay galaxy dot kv make
sure it is in the same directory as the
main.py and my main interface is going
to be my main widget so i'm going to put
main widget semicolon
okay i save it
and i can start my application by using
the right click run and i have a black
screen everything is ready for the
creation of the project
i want to define the coordinates of our
perspective points and the perspective
point will be at the center horizontally
and at 75 percent of the head here and
of course when we will resize the window
it will automatically update the
coordinates of our perspective points so
let's begin by creating some variables
perspective
point x
and let's say it's a numeric property so
we'll be able to also modify it from the
kv file why not let's see if we need
that numeric property 0 and i'm going to
copy paste this with y
and import numeric property okay so we
need to get the size of the window can
we get the size of the window from the
init
let's try def in it and i'm going to
call super
main widget
self
dot init
okay and i will add a trace print
in it
i will put my reads it's going to be str
from the self dot width okay and the
same thing for the height
plus str
self
8 okay let's try it you see that if i
start my program i have init function
that is called but we have a width and a
height of 100 because it is a default
size but of course it does not match the
size of my window and also if i resize
my window it's not going to work is it
going to work from the on parent let's
try we get parent on parent is called
when we just attach the widget to the
app in our case so i'm going to call the
same thing here the trace and i'm going
to put on parent okay let's try it
you can see that i still don't have the
size of my window here but anyway let's
keep this function because we will need
to use them in the project i'm just
going to comment in the print
and because i have no code here i need
to add pass in this function okay it's
another function called the
on size with star
arcs okay and let's try it on on size
function on size here you see that i get
a size of 1600 and 1200 which matches
the size of my window and if i resize it
i have the new size and that is
appearing here okay so this is a good
candidate to compute our perspective
point i can say that on size
self
dot perspective points don't forget to
use self here okay equal
self dot reads that i'm going to divide
by two i want to be at center
horizontally and i'm going to use
perspective point y is going to be self
dot 8 at 75 percent so i multiply by 0
dot 75
and how can i observe when the property
change i can use a function name that
will be automatically called because
it's a property and that is on
the name of the property on perspective
point x when the value of this property
change is automatically called and we
need to provide widget and value
parameters so value is going to be the
new value i can add a print and i will
say perspective x and i will print the
value the new value okay and i will do
the same for on the y okay p
y equal this new value let's try it so
you can see 1600 1200 and i have 800 for
x which is correct and 900 for the y
which is also correct so my point is
here and it's going to automatically
adapt when i change the size of the
window is it possible to do it in a
different way yes we can do that from
the kv file so i'm going to comment
these two lines and i will use the
equivalent on the kv file here we have
our main interface which is the main
widget and i'm going also to define my
main widget inside my main widget i have
these properties so i can use them
perspective point x directly in my kv
file and i'm going to give a value which
is self dot width divided by 2 and
perspective point y which is going to be
7.8
multiplied by 0 75 and if i start again
my program you can see that it's still
going to work you see that the values of
my perspective point are automatically
updated how is it possible because here
we give the value of the width on the
head it's because it's a binding when
you write something like this in the kv
file it will automatically update the
value of the property
when saved.reads and
self.hate will be modified and of course
these two functions are going to be
called whether the value of the property
is changed from the python file or from
the kv file so that's all for the
perspective point i'm going just to
comment the prints and we need to put
pass
because we have no code inside functions
okay and then we can move to the next
video
now we want to display our vertical line
so we are going to display the vertical
lines into two dimension first and then
we will apply a transform to have the
perspective and we will display your
line totally from the bottom zero to the
height of the window we will have a line
at the center and we will have other
vertical lines spaced by the same amount
that we will compute by a percentage on
the width of the window we want our game
to adapt to the size of the window so
let's do this but first we are going to
display only one line to make a first
test
so i'm going to
create a function in it
vertical lines that i'm going to call
from the
init function
self not init vertical lines okay i'm
going to add a line instruction in the
canvas
with
self.canvas and all the lines will be
displayed in white so i will put a color
instruction with one one one for white i
need to import this tv graphics context
instructions don't take this one okay
and i will add a line instruction with
points
take care it's an s at points equal and
we are going to give a list of points i
need to import this line instruction kv
graphics vertex instructions first to
make a test we want to make a vertical
line that will be at x with 100 so we
are going to give x1 100 y1 0 x2 100
y2 100 okay let's save and try this so
you can see we have our vertical line at
the good coordinates okay i can resize
my window it's still display here let's
do something more let's display this
line always at the center of the window
so even when we resize the window it's
going to be updated to the right
position depending on the window reads
how can i do that
i have to save this line instruction and
i need to create a new variable line
equal node and i will do
self not line equal line and from that
this line instruction is already in the
canvas i will just update my line so i'm
going to create a function
update
vertical lines and what i want to do is
to give my lines new points points equal
my new points and i want to display it
at the center of the window so you may
say why i don't put the center here like
for example self dot weights divided by
two yeah why not so let's try that and
see what it gave and you can see that my
line is displayed here and not in the
center of the window why because it took
the value 100 divided by 250 that is
available at the init here because we
call it from because we call it from
here or you may say we need to call this
function on the on size
no we should not do that because if we
do that it's going to create over and
over new instructions in the canvas and
that's not what we want to do we want to
create only one instructions so i'm
going to remove that from here we want
to call it from the init that's correct
we create our instruction and then we
will just update the coordinates but
never call that anymore so i'm just
going to update the coordinates in the
update vertical lines and this function
yes i will call it from the unsize
function self dot update vertical lines
so what i give x1 i want to give the
width here i can go back to 100 for
example and here i will compute the
center x which is
simpler to it divided by two and you
need to give hints coordinates else if
you have some decimals in the
coordinates and the line will be drawn
but not totally well so you have to take
care about that x1 it's the center x and
0 for the y
and then we go to the same x but 100 in
our example let's see if it's working
well you see that it's at the center of
the window and if i resize my window i
can see the line is moving and always
align to the center of the window so we
can just by assigning new points to this
line you can see that the display is
updated
and you may say okay but why we did not
update it only the y here and do like
points of zero equals something because
if you do that it will not trigger the
update of the display so what you need
to do is to give a new value to this
points property okay so now that we have
one line working and adapting to the
size of the window we want to have our
multiple vertical lines and we are going
to start from the center line but we
will have lines on the left and lines on
the right we are going to define the
total number of lines and we are going
to define also the spacing between the
different lines and it's going to be in
our case 10 percent of the total width
of the window okay let's do this i can
delete my line because we will now
manage multiple vertical
lines it's going to be a list of lines
and i'm going to create different
numbers that we want vertical and b
lines for example seven lights of course
we will be able to change that numbers
laters if we want and vertical lines
spacing that's space between the
different lines and why i don't give a
value in dp are in pixels because
imagine if you're on an ipad or phone
it's going to be different display size
so we need to adapt the size of our game
depending on the size of the window so i
have to give a percentage on the width
of the window i will say that it's going
to be 10
0.1 percentage in screen
widths okay perfect in the init i will
initialize my different lines so here i
don't want to do that anymore but i will
just add the different instructions in
the canva i will not give any points i
just want to create my lines and later
in the updates i will reassign the
points to each line so here i just want
to do a new line and in a loop of course
for i in range 0 2 and b
vertical and b lines i will create a
line that i will add in my vertical
lines up and i put self
so in my vertical lines i will have
seven lines in our case now when i go to
the update function i want to reassign
my points to each line so i'm going to
command that and of course i will loop
same loop for every lines i need to
assign the points of this vertical line
of the index dot points equal something
how can we compute that what we can
compute is the x of the central line we
can rename that to central line x
and what's going to happen for example
is that we are going to have this
central line here but we need to draw
also lines on the left and lines on the
right and we will have three lines on
the left plus this one four and three
lines on the right to go to seven okay
so what we can do is to have an offset
that will be negative at the beginning
and that will be the half of nb lines so
we can do divided by two in our case if
i do int of this it's going to be three
so i'm going to start on the left
and in my loop i will increment this
offset so i have a kind of index of the
number of the line it's going to be the
negative 3 line totally on the left
negative 2 negative 1
then 0 1 2 3 and i will then compute the
x of the line from the central line and
the offset so i can compute it here
line x
is equal to
central line x
plus the offset the offset is negative
first so it's going to be on the left
first multiply by the spacing between
the different lines so it's going to be
self dot v lines spacing but line
spacing is a percentage on the window
width so we first need to compute the
spacing i'm going to write it here
spacing is equal to self dot
v line spacing multiply by self
dot width okay and i will multiply my
spacing here okay so first in the first
loop i get my offset minus three i get
central line x
plus minus three the spacing so it's
going to be the line totally on the left
then i increment my offset so from minus
three i go to minus 2 so it's going to
be the next vertical line then minus 1.
then the center is going to be 0 in the
offset so it's going to be at the
central line and then we have plus 1
spacing plus 2 plus 3. of course now i
need to give my points so x is a line x
and i give a 0 for the y then again line
x and i'm going to give the self dot 8
so we can draw the line totally to the
top let's try that okay you can see i
have my different lines something i'm
missing you can see that the drawing of
the line is a bit weird like we have
some lines that are more visible than
others is because we need to put the
hint
here in the coordinates it's important
not to have floating numbers okay let's
try again so now you see it's better and
we have our lines that are displayed and
that adapts to the width of the window
it's perfect of course we can change
these numbers for example i can put less
here zero
four let's say and we have
more lines okay so why do i put a odd
number here for example if i put four
lines and i go back to my zero one
what's going to happen it's because it's
not going to be balanced from the center
line we have two lines on the left and
only one here to make four lines so for
this to work we need to have an odd
number like 5 7 11 for example so let's
keep these values that's all for the
vertical lines and let's continue on the
project
we were able to display our vertical
lines in a two dimensional space we use
the vertical lines spacing to define the
equal space between the different lines
and we also defined the vertical number
of lines for example here 5 our vertical
lines start from a y of 0 to the height
of the screen how can we transform that
display to a perspective display we
already have our perspective point
perspective x and perspective y and we
want to display our vertical lines this
way on the axis when y equals zero we
are going to keep the same value of the
v line spacing but the more we go closer
to the vertical points the more the
horizontal axis is going to be smaller
to do this we are going to implement a
function that we will call transform
perspective it will take the 2d
coordinates as an input and it will
return the transform coordinates for
example if i take this line which is
going to be displayed here in the
perspective i have two points i have
this point here point number one and
point number two you can see that my
point number one is going to be
displayed here at the same position but
the point number two will be displayed
at the same position as a perspective
point to go from here to here is what i
call the version number one of our
transformation function because it's
going to evolve in the project we will
see that later so how are we going to go
from here to here it's going to be
mathematical computation of linear
proportions if i go back to my
perspective representation i have my x
and y axis starting from 0 and going to
the maximum y of height and maximum x of
width
this is my display
this represents my window i have my
perspective x here for this line and
perspective y here for the example we
are going to take this blue line it has
two points point number one here x one
x1 y1 this line in the two-dimensional
space is display as this red line so the
other point is here point x2 y2 these 2d
coordinates is what i will give to my
transformation function as an input
first thing we can compute is about the
y transformation i want that when the y
is at the maximum value which is 8 and
which is the case for my point 2 i want
it to be at a maximum of perspective y
so i'm going to make a proportion here
if it is 0 we keep 0 if it is 8 we
divide by the height and we multiply by
perspective y to be here so my
transformation y equal point y
divided by the maximum height and
multiply by the perspective y also in
the chord we will add some condition to
avoid going above the perspective y even
if you are above the height so if i
apply this transform y my point 2 is
here now we want to compute the x and
you can see that the x is going to be
closer and closer to the perspective x
here i have my div x and here i have my
diff y
d x is the same value for point one and
point two it's going to be the point x
minus the perspective x concerning d f y
i'm going to use the transform y so for
the point one it's going to be
perspective y
minus zero so we have the maximum value
here which is perspective y for the
point two my point two with the
transform y is already here so it's
going to be zero perspective y
minus perspective y d f y equal
perspective y minus the transform y how
can i compute my x to compute the value
of the x you need to understand that the
delta of x
depends on the y
the more we go closer to the perspective
points vertically the more my d x will
be smaller and if i go halfway
vertically my div x will have a value of
50 percent so what we want to have is a
proportion variable that is one when
diff y is the maximum value perspective
y and that is 50 percent when my d5 is
at halfway and we are going to apply
this vertical proportion to the
difference of x and we will call that as
a factor y factor y equals the
difference y divided by the maximum
value perspective y factor y equals 1 in
the case of the point number 1 and it
equal zero in the case of point number
two because we have zero in factor y for
the point number two so transform x will
not have any difference with the
perspective x transform x equal
perspective x plus
the d x
at the proportion
of the factor y so multiply by factor y
that means that the x for point number
one will be here perspective x plus the
full and difference because we have a
full factor y then for this point in the
middle we are going to be starting from
perspective x plus the half of the diff
x and for the point number two we are
going to be here plus
zero because of factor y is equal to
zero and of course for the points on the
left we are going to have a d x and that
is a negative so we will add this
negative value for the left part this is
correct and finally we will return that
transform coordinates take the time on
your site to look about this and maybe
watch again this video and when you are
ready we are going to move to the next
video to implement this transformation
function
we have our vertical lines and we have
our perspective point and now we want to
display the lines in perspective so how
can we do that you may say we can take
this coordinate here and then we take
the coordinate of the perspective point
and that's it we trace our lines okay
but that's not what i want to do because
we will need to trace also the
horizontal lines and other elements on
the display so i choose to have another
approach which is to have a transform
function we are going to have a function
that will take the input coordinates x
and y so we will give the two dimension
coordinates in the input and on the
output we will get the coordinates in
perspective that means if you give this
coordinate for example you will have the
same in the output but if we give this
coordinate here with which correspond to
where we trace our 2d line then you will
get this coordinate in the output
tracing the line like this and by using
a transform function we will be able to
use multiple transform function that
will makes it possible to have a
standard 2d transform that will not
transform the coordinates and another
function to transform in perspective so
it's going to be easy to change the
display from 2d to perspective very
easily i will show you concretely how it
works so first what we are going to do
is to define a new function that is
going to be transform and we will give x
and y and this is going to return
something and this something is the
result of a transform
function so we will have transform 2d
that will also take x and y
and this one does not change anything so
it just returns
x and y okay so our transform function
does not do anything for now but the
interest is that we can have another one
which is going to be the transform
perspective and this we need to
implement it okay that's what we're
going to do in this video and why do i
do this of course the transform function
we will need to call it before we
display the light we are going to do
that but why i do this because
we can
use either our 2d transform or transform
perspective so we can go easily from
perspective or from two-dimension okay
so of course here i return the same
coordinate so if i just use the
transform perspective it's not going to
change anything so interest is what is
that we will compute all the coordinates
in 2d but just before going to the
display we are going to transform the
coordinates and how can we do that we
are going to compute x1 and y1 that is
going to be a self dot transform and it
will take the 2d coordinates line x
and 0 in our case okay and here we will
display x1 and
y1 and for x2 and y2 we are going to
take the same input so align x for x and
save that 8 for the y okay so i can put
x 2 and y 2. ok so if i start my program
again of course it's going to be the
same thing because we don't change the
coordinates here perfect
so let's begin to write this function
and what we want to do is this instead
of drawing until the top we want to draw
until the perspective x and y first
let's compute the y
so for the y if we give 0 we will still
stay here but if we give the window
height it's going to have a result of
the perspective y okay so we need to
make a proportion to go to this maximum
value that means here i will write
transform y
that is equal to my value of the y that
i'm going to divide by the self dot hate
self hate is the height of the window
okay so when the y equals the maximum
value which is the height of the window
it's going to be a value of 1 here
7.8 divided by 7.8 equal one and this
value of one i want to multiply it by
the self not perspective point y so when
i reach the maximum of the window in
fact the return coordinates in fact the
return y of the transform function will
be here and if i go above then i'm going
to be stuck here okay so if the
transform y
is greater than the self perspective
point y is going to be equal to that we
cannot go after the perspective point
okay so i can begin to return this new
coordinate here in my transform
perspective make sure that you use this
transform perspective function and if i
try it you can see that this time i'm
stuck here okay it's no more going to
the top of the window but to 75 percent
perfect also i'm going always to return
inch coordinates in the 2d and in the
transform perspective so we are sure we
use
non-floating coordinates ok it will not
change much in my case perfect now let's
compute for the x position what do we
want to do for the x position for
example if we take this line you can see
that the more we go to the right to
reach this x point of the perspective
point and how can we compute that what
we will look is at this
x coordinate of the perspective point
and we will compute the difference here
it's what we will call the d x is going
to be 100 percent
when the diff
y because the d5 is going to be
perspective y minus the current y
coordinate is going to be equal to the
maximum value which is perspective y so
when we have 100 percent difference and
the more we decrease the percentage of
hate
proportionally the more we are going to
decrease the difference of the if x
so let's write the diff x and diff y
d f
x
it's going to be the value of my x for
example this value here that is greater
than the x of the perspective points so
it's going to be x minus first minus f
dot perspective point x
but if
y is going to be
perspective point y because this is a
greater value here
and our y is smaller minus
r
t l y not the y because the y can go to
the window height
but we want to have the proportion until
the perspective point y so that's why we
need to use the tier y
what is the proportion
why proportional will be equal to 1
when
we are at the bottom when d f y
equal to perspective point y okay and
it's going to be equal to zero when
if y equals zero so it's a proportion we
want to compute for
a y here on this axis how much
proportion we have here is going to be
100 percent here is going to be 50
percent
and here it's going to be 75 percent and
0
the more we go to the perspective point
we must we decrease this proportion
because we are going to multiply the
different x by this proportion here on
the y axis so this proportion y
is equal to my coordinate try that i'm
going to divide is going to be my diff y
that i'm going to divide by perspective
point y and you can see that
when my div y is zero my proportion is
zero but when my diff y is maximum is
going to have this value perspective
point y so it's going to have a value of
1 okay so my proportion is correct here
how can i compute my transformation x
we are going to start from perspective
point
x and we are going to add the difference
but the difference is going to be a
factor of this y proportion okay so
let's try that okay so we agree that we
start from here perspective point x and
we will add the difference which is the
compute here of the difference multiply
by the factor of the heights that means
if i'm at 50 percent my difference here
is only 50 which makes a point here okay
so let's try that and you can see that
this time
it's working well so i can resize my
window in every dimensions it's working
well i can also change the number of
lines and the spacing between the line
if i put for example 25 percent between
the different lines i have something
like this which is more interesting and
i can also add more lines for example 15
okay so we have something good and what
is interesting of course is that we can
change
the transformation here i just can
uncomment transform 2d and command the
perspective so i go back to my 2d
display and it's going to be useful when
we want to do the development because
all the logic of the program will be in
2d and at the very last moment we will
transform the coordinates to the
perspective so it's going to be far more
easy to work like that i just go back to
perspective and back to the previous
numbers here 7 and 10 percent and that's
it for the perspective transform and we
move on to the next video
we have our perspective line okay i want
to do a slight modification i don't want
to have a line here i want to have a way
here i want this to be centered because
for our game we will have our spaceship
on the way and not on the line so what
you will do for this exercise is that
you will shift the x coordinates so that
not a line is centered but away
first i suggest you that you go back to
the 2d transforms so you go to transform
and you uncomment the 2d and you go back
here and for example you are going to
reduce the number of lines of course
it's going to work not with a nod number
of lines this time but with an even
number of lines so i'm going to put four
you can see that this line is centered
but i wanted to shift everything to the
right of the half of the spacing i let
you do the exercise and i will show you
after the solution
[Music]
so i want this part this way to be
centered and not this line so we need to
shift by the half of a line spacing to
the right how can we do that of course
it's not going to be in the transform
all the logic of the game is going to be
transformed at the end just for the
display but we need to modify the
coordinates of the lines that we draw in
the update vertical lines and for
example we can turn the central line x
coordinate that's possible to add
a half of the spacing here okay or we
can just change the offset and to say
that the offset is a plus 0.5 plus a
half of line because the offset is going
to be multiplied by the spacing so in
case of starting at minus 2 because in
our case we have 4 here it's going to be
minus 1.5
then minus 0 5 then plus 0 5 and plus
1.5 okay so you may say yes but i say
that we don't use a floating point in
the coordinates yes but it's okay here
because we are going to multiply by the
spacing and after that we are going to
remove the floating points so at that
stage it's going to be multiplied first
by a spacing that is going to be a quite
high number here okay so let's try that
this time we have a way centered in the
window okay it's perfect
and we can go back to the perspective
mode and this time you can see that we
are centered with a way in the middle
it's perfect let's add more lines for
example 10 lines and a little bit more
of spacing and this time you can
understand that it's far better
concerning our game so we will put
spaceship here and we will be able to
move it horizontally i will show you
that later that's all for the exercise
and we continue on the project
we have our vertical lines we can
display them in perspective it's nice
and now we want to display also the
horizontal lines i'm going to go back to
the 2d display so i will comment that
okay and i will reduce the number of
lines just so that it's more clear what
we are doing here i'm going to go back
to four lines and 10 percent spacing so
we have this
and what we want to do is to display
some horizontal lines we are going to
have the same logic as the vertical
lines we are going to have a number of
lines we will start from y equal zero
from here and then we will define the
spacing for the horizontal lines we will
not start from zero to the reads but we
will need to compute the x min and x max
which will depend on the vertical lines
and we will display our different lines
with the same spacing so let's do that
i'm going to copy paste what we did for
the vertical lines and it's going to be
h horizontal number of lines i'm going
to keep this value 4
and horizontal lines spacing for example
0.2 20
percentage in screen
height and i'm going to call that
horizontal lines
okay and i will have the same logic init
function and update function so i'm just
going to copy paste that and it's going
to be horizontal and the same here for
the update function oh re horizontal
okay and i will go to take this init and
update function and i just copy paste in
this code that we will of course
change so first the name of the function
horizontal
okay and the same for the update
function in the init it's going to be
quite straightforward because it's going
to be almost the same thing we are going
to loop on the number of horizontal
lines and we are going to add in our
whole re horizontal lines list the
different lines okay that's done for the
init function for the update function
it's going to be different so i'm going
just to remove all this code update
horizontal lines i want to loop on the
number of horizontal line and what is
going to be the line
y
and the line y is going to start from
zero
plus something from the index that we
are going to multiply what do we need to
multiply by
the spacing
h line spacing which is twenty percent
self dot h spacing twenty percent of
the screen height
yes it's called horizontal but it's for
the horizontal line but this spacing is
vertical so it depends so it's twenty
percent of the height of the window it
depends on the height okay i don't need
to put a zero plus here i can just
delete it so we will need to compute the
x min and the x max for now we just put
some values in it x mean zero x max
equal self dot reads okay we will change
that later so here i can put my
coordinates we start from the point one
is at x min and the line y for both of
them and the point two is at x max okay
i don't have any offset in this case
and that's it
so let's try it and see what it gives i
don't have my vertical lines anymore and
this is maybe because i have replaced
some code here update vertical lines
update horizontal lines and that's
correct it's because i forgot to change
here the points of my horizontal
lines okay so i was raising my vertical
lines make sure you don't have v here
and that it's horizontal lines in the
horizontal function okay let's try it
one more time and now you can see we
have our horizontal lines and it's
adapting to the height of the window
that's good what we need to do now is to
compute the x min and the x max because
i don't want this part here i want to
stop here and this depends on the
vertical lines if you look at the code
for the update vertical lines you will
see that we first compute this offset
so we know the position of the x of the
line totally on the left so we can reuse
that and we are going to keep this
computation for the minimum x and the
line totally on the left and we will put
a minus for the opposite direction of
the offset for the maximum for the x max
so i'm going to copy these three lines
and to paste them here of course in the
same logic here i can define
a spacing
y variable that is going to be my
horizontal line spacing multiplied by
the height of the window okay i can do
that it's the same thing but to go back
to the computation of x-men and x-max
i'm going to use the central line x
plus the offset which is negative it's
good because we go to the left it's
x-min multiply by the spacing and for
the max i'm going to do the same
but i'm going to go to the other
direction for the maximum offset you may
think it's strange because x minions on
the left so why i add something we add
something because the offset is negative
you can change the logic if you want we
can change the size and put plus and
minus here and to invert the signs here
if you want it's going to be the same
thing let's start it and see what it
gives so now you can see we have the
good result we display the vertical
lines and it's stopping at the right
position it's correct let's try it in
the perspective mode i go back to my
transformation function and i'm going to
and comment the perspective mode we have
something like that which is quite good
but you may see that it's a bit strange
what we have here so let's add some more
lines to better see what is the problem
that we have put 15 okay let's try that
so it's quite nice but you may think why
this style is smaller this one seems to
be longer yes so we will need to solve
that that's one of the problems that we
have it's because we have a constant
spacing between the different lines here
you may think that this spacing is
higher than this one but in fact that's
not the case if you put your finger on
the screen you can see that the spacing
is constant here for example i can show
you i can measure the height between
these two points is going to be
60
58 pixels and if i go between these two
points it's also 58 pixels but to have a
good perspective impression we will need
to change that we will need to update
our transform function so we don't have
that phenomenon and we will need to
change the spacing between the different
tiles so that the spacing is not
constant i'm going to explain you that
in the next videos
we have defined a spacing between the
different lines and the number of
horizontal lines and then we use our
transformation function to display it in
the perspective space but we have this
phenomenon that is we think that the
tiles at the front are shorter than the
deeper tiles and this is because we kept
a constant
spacing between the horizontal lines we
are going to change that to get another
result to get something like this on the
right so we have a kind of attraction to
the perspective the more we go closer to
it the more we get attracted so the
spacing is bigger on the front and it
gets smaller and smaller between the
different slides we previously spoke
about the factor y factor y is a
proportional vertical factor that means
100 percent
of distance from the perspective point
and the more we go closer to the
perspective point the more the factor
will decrease eighty percent from it
sixty percent from it forty percent how
can we get something like we have on the
right the idea is to get a factor why
that is smaller than expected that means
it's going to go faster to the
perspective point so you may say yeah we
can multiply it by something that is
less than one for example 0.5 so instead
of 0.8 we get 0.4 but if we do that and
if we multiply 1 by 0.5 we are going to
start at 0.5 so it's only going to make
the display smaller it's not going to
make something like this we want to keep
factor 1 for the maximum but we want it
to decrease faster than linearly so i
had the idea to make the factor multiply
so i had the idea to multiply the factor
by himself for example instead of having
0.8 here for this line we are going to
have 0.8 multiply by 0.8 and it's going
to be smaller than 0.8 and this is
called the factor squared factor y
multiplied by itself so if i take this
first value i get 0 64. so it's going to
be displayed here 0 6 multiplied by 0 6
equals 0 36 we are going to go faster to
the perspective point it's a kind of
attraction behavior for this formula
this formula makes a kind of attraction
behavior and we are going to apply this
to our transformation function this is a
compute number 2. how does it works so
we agree that we have perspective y here
this is the maximum value that we can
have for the
vertical spacing and it's going to be a
factor of one i put in yellow the
modifications in the transform function
i just rename this variable because we
will use it as an intermediate value so
before i call it the try but now it's a
linear y lean y because that's the
linear proportion of the y value from
the screen head to the perspective y
okay so we just use it as an
intermediate value but most important is
this new line the factor y is multiplied
by himself then i get my trx which is
the same thing as before perspective x
plus the difference multiplied by the
factor but the compute is going to be
different because the factor has changed
okay and most important this new line to
compute the try we start from
perspective y and we are going to
subtract because this is the biggest
value we are going to subtract the
factor y
multiplied by the perspective y that
means if we are here with a factor of 1
we are going to start from perspective y
minus
1 multiplied by perspective y which is
0. concerning this second line i will
start from here perspective y
multiply by the factor of 0 64 on this
total height so it's going to be here
and then we will return these new
coordinates let's implement that in the
code right now i go back to the project
and we previously saw that we had this
strange behavior of smaller tiles here
okay let's change the transform
perspective function it's not going to
change anything for the 2d display of
course because we are inside our
perspective function so i'm just going
to rename this value a linear y okay and
i'm going to use it here we have a
factor y in fact where is our factor y
it's what we called previously
proportion y so i'm going just to rename
this also factor y okay
now the new line is going to be factor y
equal factor y multiply by factor y okay
and i'm also going to compute my t r y
which is
self perspective y minus is a factor
multiplied by the maximum height
so yes of course here you may say we can
put
1 minus
factor and the total multiplied by this
is going to be the same thing okay
anyway i want to keep like i put on the
slide but it's going to give the same
results and let's try that
so you can see that this time we have
this perspective effect we don't have
this previous problem but also i want to
show you something we can accentuate the
attraction because here what we did is
to multiply two times factor y but we
can also multiply it three times or four
times if we want or we can also use a
power function paul power function takes
the value and we give how many times we
want to multiply it for example by two
times is what we did before that means
this is the same as doing factor y
multiplied by factor y two times and we
can put for example four times to
accentuate the attraction let's try this
so the problem is that the spacing is
very high between the horizontal lines
so we can just change it a bit
horizontal line spacing let's put zero
one for example okay so we have
something like that and we can also have
more spacing on the vertical lines for
example.25
okay so we have something like this we
have a real effect of perspective which
is really nice we are going to keep it
like this and we continue on the project
now we want to have this animation of
moving forward into the game how are we
going to do that we are going to change
the display of all horizontal lines and
we are going to shift them downstairs
that means we are going to subtract on
the y coordinate when we begin to move
forward then we shift everything and
down you can see that this yellow line
goes here and that this blue line goes
out of the display
and then we continue like this but you
can see that if we continue and continue
to shift the line after a moment we will
have no more lines to display because
all the lines will be out of the display
that's why we will need to implement a
kind of looping mechanism that means
when we shift more than the spacing than
the vertical spacing between two lines
then we go back to the original position
to make this shifting possible we are
going to implement a new variable that
we are going to call current offset y
and we are going to apply this offset to
all the y coordinates of the horizontal
lines we will also need to have an
update function that will be called
regularly 60 times per second this is
our number of frames 60 frames per
second and every time our update
function is called we will update the
offset to increment it and to have the
condition also of the loop of course we
can also control the speed of the
movement for example we can increment
per one at every update or increment per
two or three so we are going also to
define a speed variable are you ready so
let's do that right now i go back to the
code and i'm going to create my update
function so i go totally at the bottom
here in the main widget and i will
create a new function
update function it's a function that we
will call in a clock schedule so it's
going to give us a delta time variable
i'm just going to add a print update
okay now we need to call this function
regularly so i'm going to go to the init
function here and after the init of my
lines i'm going to add a clock not
schedule
interval and i'm going to call my update
function with the time interval if i put
1 it's going to be called one time per
second if i put 10 it's going to be
called every 10 seconds so i want it to
be called 60 times per second so i need
to
divide the time of one second by 60. you
have to import cloud from tv properties
take care of not taking this one but
from qv properties okay if i start my
program i can see that the update
function is called regularly okay so now
what are we going to do in the update
function we are going to call the update
vertical and horizontal lines in case we
want to change the coordinates of these
lines we need to update the coordinates
so we will do that in the update
functions we don't need to do this in
the on size anymore take care of putting
the pass here because we don't have code
anymore why we can do that because even
if you resize the window the update
function is going to be called anyway so
it's going to be refreshed here okay i'm
going to comment on the print let's just
start the program and see that we did
not broke anything okay the behavior is
working fine i can still resize my
window and it's working so now i want to
shift my horizontal lines in the update
horizontal line which is called
regularly now i'm going to add something
so i go to this function update
horizontal lines and you see that we
compute the coordinates and we have the
line y
and in the line y i want to add or
subtract something because we will go
downstairs so i'm going to subtract my
self current
offset
y we need to define this variable and
the value of this variable is going to
evolve in the update function so each
time we will call this update horizontal
lines it's going to have different
coordinates so let's initialize our
current offset y i'm going to give the
value
of zero here and in the update function
i'm going to increment by one this value
i need to use self here okay so if i
start my program what's happening you
can see that it's working okay i go back
to the 2d mode okay you can see that we
have our lines going down
it's nice but what's happening if i put
just a little bit lines here for example
only five lines you can see that it's
going down and after a moment i have
nothing more to display because all the
lines are out of the screen so i need to
do something like a kind of looping but
also the speed is quite low so i want to
change the speed let's put eight lines
for example so we have something like
that okay and i want to increase the
speed how can i do that instead of
adding plus one i'm going to add
something else here and it's going to be
a value that i will define as the
speed and let's say we give four okay
then i will increment by
self dot speed and it's going to be
faster okay and if i go back to the
perspective mode you can see that it's
also working well and after a moment i
have nothing more to display okay
so i go back to the 2d mode and we have
to implement this looping mechanism i
want to go back in the past when my
offset is greater or equal
than the vertical spacing between two
horizontal lines if i go to my update
horizontal lines you can see that the
spacing is here
between two lines okay so i'm going to
get this value and if i'm just
using an offset
with
this value of the spacing i can just go
back upstairs to that value and it's
going to make the illusion of the loop
for example i can test
if
offset is greater or equal than the
spacing it's working because the spacing
between two lines is always the same and
you may think yes but in perspective
it's no more the case yes of course but
the perspective function is called at
the end so we don't care about that we
always do all the compute in two
dimension and the perspective will be
called at the end so for us the spacing
between two horizontal line is always
constant and always this value if the
offset is greater than the spacing what
do we do we go back
and it's like we shift from one level
okay and now if i start my program again
you can see that when i go down it's
putting a line again here so from this
point of view it's always looping and if
i add more lines and going above the top
of the screen i will not see this
phenomenon so here if i do for example
15 lines you see that i have the
illusion that it's always looping and
it's going to work also in perspective
mode of course okay let's try it okay so
it's working well my screen recording is
in 15 frames per second so it may not
look very freed on the video but on my
computer it looks very freed at 60
frames per second the behavior is good
that's all for this video and let's
continue on the project
our program is working fine okay we can
move forward in the level that's nice
but we need to change something very
important
look in the update function we have this
parameter the dt
delta time and i did not explain you why
we have this in delta time here and how
we can use it in fact you remember we
said that we want to call this function
update 60 times per second in fact it's
1 16
in fact it's going to be called one time
every 1 16 of second but it's not going
to be as precise as this because maybe
your computer or your smartphone will be
busy to do something else and when he
will trigger the call to the update
function maybe it's not going to be as
precise as this timing and so you may go
from 60 frames per second to a little
bit less than that 50 or 30 frames on
old machines for example but the problem
is that in that case because the update
function will be called less regularly
the game especially in the speed
at which we go forward in the level is
going to go slower and so the game is
going to be far more easy to play on
older machines and we don't want that we
want the game to have the same speed in
the level even if we don't have the
exact number of frames per second how
are we going to manage that we are going
to use this delta time which is a
precise value and of course if finally
we spend twice the time that we expected
between two calls of the update function
we should go forward twice in the time
so this is proportional to the delta
time let's print the delta time value
and see what we have delta time and
let's
print str of delta time and also i want
to print
the
expected value which is 1 divided by 60
str 1.0 divided by 60.0 okay let's run
this and see what we have so i expand
the window here okay i stop the program
and i go upstairs and i see i get
different value of delta time the
reference value is 0.016
okay so here we can see that it's almost
the right value that's correct
so the delta time is a time difference
with the previous call of the update
function so you can see that it's quite
irregular sometimes it's a little bit
more sometimes a little bit less
sometimes more sometimes less
so it's not totally perfect
but anyway we want to take this factor
into account you see that if i multiply
by 60 especially 1 divided by 60 if i
multiply it by 60 it's going to be 1
it's going to be around 1 for the delta
time so we can try that
delta time multiplied by 60 and i'm
going to remove the remaining here okay
let's try again okay i stopped my
program and you see that we have
something around 1 sometime a bit above
and as i told you for example if you
have 1.5 it's like we spend 50 percent
more time
than expected so instead of using this
value saved speed we are going to
multiply it by the time factor and for
us
the time factor is delta time multiplied
by 60. okay i'm going to comment on the
print you agree that normally time
factor should be always 1. but in
reality if we spend more time between
two update calls for example twice the
time let's say 30 frames per second the
time factor is going to be equal to two
so we are going to add twice
the value of the speed because we are
twice slower on the machine so at the
end per unit of time that means after
one second we will make the same
progression whatever the frame per
second so we need to take this time
factor into account even if i think on
your machine you will not really see the
difference here in fact it's far better
to manage the time to have a consistent
game on every devices that's perfect and
let's move on to the next lecture
for this exercise i'm going to ask you
to add movement on the horizontal
position
that means in the same way of using an
offset y you will need to use also an
offset x to get something that looks
like this so we are going to move on the
left or on the right up to you okay you
will add this movement on the update
function and you will need to create
these variables
speed
x for example 3 and
current offset
x equals zero you need to use this
variable in the code of course you will
not use it in the transform function but
you need to apply it to the vertical
lines and also to the horizontal lines
you will not need to have a loop
mechanism because when we will go at the
end of the track it's okay we'll go out
of the track that's not a problem we do
this exercise because later we will
manage the press of the keys so that we
can move on the left or on the right i
let you do this exercise on your side
and after that i will show you the
solution
[Music]
so i'm going to define these two
variables speed x and current offset x
of course if i go to my update function
i need to upgrade my offset so i'm going
to do self dot current offset x plus
equal to
the same thing here except that it's
going to be speed x
so we have our vertical speed which is
speed and or horizontal speed okay now
where should i use that i should use it
to offset the vertical lines so if i go
to update vertical lines you can see
that we compute the line x
so i can also use that to make a plus
and put a current offset x in here is
not mandatory because we already do that
in the transform function okay so let's
try that
it's almost good you can see that we
have this good behavior
but we also have a problem for the
horizontal lines you see that they are
not aligned with the vertical lines
anymore and that's because we need to
use also this offset in the compute of
the x min and x max in the update
horizontal lines function so i'm going
also to add this offset here and this
time you can see that if i start my
program again i have the right behavior
so you also see that every time i need
to resize my window so it's a little bit
thing i want to add here you are going
to type on google tv window size and you
will find this first link on stack
overflow and you will see that you have
this config set graphic width and hate
so you will copy these three lines from
kvconfig import config you copy these
three lines
and you put it at the very top of the
file here before any other kv import and
that's important so graphic weeds we are
going to put 900 and 400 for the height
okay let's try that now i start my
project this is working and the window
size is good that's all for the exercise
and let's move on to the next video
for this exercise we are going to
control the horizontal movement by
pressing on the screen on the left or on
the right of course it's going to be
useful for mobile's phone but for the
computer we want to manage the keyboard
key press on the left and on the right
but we will do that later for now it's
just going to be pressing on the screen
just before doing the exercise i'm going
to prepare some code first i'm going to
comment this line of code so we start
without any movement when you will press
on the left you will go on the left of
the land and on the right you will go on
the right so i'm going to write some
functions here to manage the touch on
the screen
def on touch down
then i will not do anything
yet def on
touch
up
when i release the finger okay
so here on touchdown you need to know if
you pressed on the left or on the right
of the screen and what you can do you
can look at touch.x
which is less than
self width divided by two for example if
that's the case we go on the left so i'm
just going to add a print
okay with an arrow and else
we go on the right if i do a touch up
i'm also going to add a trace up okay
let's try that you can see that if i
press on the left
i see left then up when i release my
button and on the right i can see right
then up when i release so of course
when you keep the button pressed on the
left
you will move to the left direction
until you release your button and on the
right it's going to be the same and when
you release your button you have no
movement on the horizontal axis
that means this line that we commented
will sometimes add zero or sometime add
a value or sometime decrease the value
depending on what you are doing here and
for that you will need to use an
intermediate variable that is going to
be the current
speed x and it's going to be in zero as
a default and on the update function
you are going to increment this
current speed x self okay
so i let you do the exercise right now
you need to give the right value for
this variable depending on what you are
doing here with a touch do the exercise
and then i will show you the solution
[Music]
so we need to give a value to the
current speed x
of course if we release the button we
don't want any movement anymore so it's
going to be a speed of zero but if we
press on the left we are going to give a
value here it's going to be the self
speed x
and on the opposite direction is going
to be
minus self speed x
let's see if it is working correctly
okay i press on the left i go to the
left in reality the land is moving to
the right so i have this impression that
i'm moving to the left because the
spaceship will be always at the middle
of the window okay if i press on the
right i go on the right and if i release
i have no movement but it's a little bit
slow so what we can do is to improve
this speed x by 20 by 12 for example
okay so i have a speed on the left and
on the right this is correct but on the
computer we also want to manage the
keyboard the left key and the right key
so we are going to do that in the next
video that's all for this exercise and
let's continue
let's add the keyboard management in our
project on computer we want to be able
to press the left and the right key on
the keyboard to move in the game in the
same way when we press on the screen if
you go to google and you type tv
keyboard key you will find the first
link here how do you check for keyboard
events in kivy and then you will see an
example that we can use so you can see
we get keyboard here with a window
request keyboard and then we bind the on
key drawn that is in this function and
we also give a function when the
keyboard is closed because on mobile the
keyboard can be open and close
but we will add something after so that
we only use the keyboard configuration
on computer and not on mobile this is
because on mobile the keyboard will be
displayed on the screen and that's
something we don't want so i will show
you how to do that first we are going to
copy these lines of codes okay and we
are going to adapt this so i copy this
and i go back to my init function here
i'm going to paste at the end of my init
function okay but we are going to move
the clock schedule at the end of the
function i want the clock schedule to
start the update when everything has
been initialized the window we need to
import a window from tv core window okay
i don't like this underscore before the
function name so i'm just going to
change that
here and here we need to register the on
key up also so i'm going to duplicate
this line and put on key up because we
need to know when we release the key on
keyboard up prototype of the function
i'm going to copy paste the on keyboard
on is almost the same as the on keyboard
on except we don't have the last two
parameters on keyboard up
and i'm going to put pass inside i don't
want to manage this key but i want the
left key and the
right key and inside we will need to
write our own code of course that we
will replace in a moment so i'm just
going to remove
these
okay and i have to return true to say
okay i have manage and this keypress we
are going to do the same on the on
keyboard app okay also something i need
to add is the unbind of the on key up
here okay perfect
so what do i want to do in this function
the same thing that we do when we press
on the screen so i'm just going to cut
these to function and to paste it close
to the on touchdown and untouch up on
keyboard down when we press left we are
going to do this current speed equal
speed x
and also i will comment the prints here
we don't use them anymore okay so i'm
going to do the same thing here and i
will do
the opposite here with a minus like we
do here and on the on touch up i'm going
to put the speed to zero in the on
keyboard up okay
so let's try it i'm going to start my
program first thing i can see is that my
window size is not the one we have
specified so it's something that has
been broken here we are going to have a
look at that but if i press on the left
arrow key on my keyboard on the left
it's working and on the right it's
working too and i can still click on the
window and it's also still working
that's fine so why do i have a problem
with the windowwidth if i go totally up
in my file i can see that this line has
been inserted automatically when i
wanted to import the window and i told
you we need to do this before any other
kv import so i need to move this line
just below
and i will keep this if i restart you
can see that this time my window size is
correct okay one more thing i want to
add is i don't want to configure the
keyboard in the case we are on mobile so
we need to define a function
that will say if we are on desktop
computer or if we are on mobile
dev is
desktop and for this we are going to use
something that is called platform so we
can do if platform and you can see that
i can import this from kv dot platform
okay of course we will check that this
is going to be after the kv config here
okay perfect platform will contain the
name of the platform we are running the
program that means it can be linux
windows mac os ios android so we will
check if platform
in
linux or
windows
or
mac os
x
then we will return true we will say yes
it's a desktop computer and in every
other case it's going to be false
okay so i'm going to call this function
here if self dot sorry i need to add a
tab okay is desktop and in that case we
are going to configure the keyboard we
don't want to do that in the case of
mobile okay and also i will add a
breakpoint here so we will analyze what
do we have in the platform here i will
press on the debugging mode okay so if i
put my mouse over here i have the mac os
x value so if i step it's going to be
true in my case okay this is correct i
just restart my program to see if it is
still working correctly and i can press
my left and right arrow on the keyboard
it's working well and also
when i touch the screen everything is
working perfectly that's all for this
video
[Music]
galaxy project version number two at the
end of this version two the project will
look like this so you can see we have a
pass generation i can also move and when
we detect that the ship is out of the
pass you can see this in game over but
the game is still continuing also the
speed is very slow here but it's on
purpose for this version 2 we will first
organize and structure our code we will
be able to display the path first we
will display one tile then we will be
able to display multiple tiles and after
that we will generate our pass with the
land generation algorithm we will also
display the spaceship and check if the
spaceship is still on the track if
that's not the case we will display game
over but the game will still continue at
that stage are you ready to start let's
do it
before starting let's clean and organize
our code a little bit because on the
main widget we have a lot of functions
and a lot of code so i want to separate
a bit some functions in some other
python files and for example we can move
all these transform functions
to another file so you are going to
create a new python file and you will
call it
transforms okay now when i go back here
i will take transform 2d and transform
perspective and i will cut that and i
will paste it directly in the
transform.py and now you can see that if
you try to start the program it's not
working anymore because it says main
widget has no attribute transform so we
need to tell the main widget that it has
to include these functions
so we need to go inside as a main widget
so you can go anywhere inside the class
but not outside and we'll just write the
code here at the first line inside the
main widget and we will write from
transforms that's the name of the file
import and the name of the functions
transform2d and transform perspective
okay now i can start my program it's
working fine what else can we move i
want to move all the user interactions
all the keyboards and touch functions
so if i go a little bit downstairs i
have on keyboard down on keyboard app on
touchdown and touch up i want to move
these functions on a new file that we
will call user
actions and i will paste that inside the
same way i have to import this from the
main widget so from user actions import
keyboard up on keyboard down and onto
chop on touchdown i can also move
the keyboard close function okay and i
will paste it at the beginning of the
file i also need to import it
so i go back here and i will add import
keyboard closed perfect let's start
again to see if it is still working okay
perfect and before we finish on this
video i want to clean a bit my code so i
will remove some functions that we don't
use for example on parent
on size and on perspective point x and y
we don't use them so let's delete all
these functions now that our code is
more organized and clean we can continue
on the project
we want to be able to display the tiles
in our games so how are we going to do
that here i display the vertical lines
for example four vertical lines and four
horizontal lines let's say that if i
want to display this style we will say
that this one is a tile zero and the one
just on the right will be the tile one
zero it's going to be a coordinate
system with x and y for the tiles so
this one will be zero one this one minus
one 0 2 and this is what i call the tile
index t i x t i y and it will be useful
to have a function and get tile
coordinates that takes this index and
that will return the actual x and y
coordinates of this lower and left point
because if we have this lower left point
we can also have the upper right point
if we give the plus one x index and plus
one y index here so from these two
coordinates it will be easy to draw the
tile on the screen to implement this
function we need to get the coordinates
of the different lines and for that we
are going to assign some index to the
different lines for example on this line
we will say that it is a line zero this
one the line minus one this one the plus
one and the plus two of course if we
have more lines we will have the minus
two minus three plus four etc concerning
the vertical lines it's going to be the
same line index 0 line index 1 index 2
ok first we will get the x coordinates
of the different vertical lines and we
will write this function
get line x from index for example if i
give index 0 i'm going to get the x
coordinate of this line if i give index
2 i will get the x coordinate of this
line and after we will also implement
the get line y from index for the
horizontal lines and this will makes it
far more easy to implement get tile
coordinates and also we will use this
new function to rework the code inside
update vertical lines and update
horizontal lines so how can we implement
this new function here you can see we
have the central line x and we have the
spacing between two different lines the
spacing is the v line's spacing
multiplied by the self width if i have
an index of 0 you can see that i'm not
aligned in the center of the screen but
i'm halfway on the left
so we will compute an offset that will
be index
minus 0.5 so the line x will be the
central line x
plus the offset multiplied by the
spacing if i have the index of 0 i have
the offset of minus 0.5 so i start from
my central line x
and then i go left 0.5 times of the
spacing and i arrive here if my index is
minus 1 i will have the offset of minus
1.5 and that if i start from the central
line x i am at minus 1.5 the spacing
okay and we also need to add the current
offset x which is a global offset when
we press on the left and right keys
let's go back to the project and let's
implement this new function i'm going to
write this new function just above this
update vertical lines
def
get a line x
from index
and so we have this index parameter i
will take what we did here okay we have
our central line x that we compute from
the center of the screen finally i think
it would be better to take the
perspective x because perspective x is
also at the middle of the screen but it
will allow us maybe later to change the
position of the perspective point so it
will be better to write here self dot
perspective point x
okay we have the spacing and for the
offset it's going to be different it's
going to be index
minus 0.5
when the index is 0 i want to be halfway
on the left
so my line x
will be central line x plus the offset
multiplied by the spacing and also plus
the current of set x so we have our
offset when we want to go to the left
and the right when we press the keys
okay and i will return this line x of
course i can rework my function here so
i can delete all of that and i will get
the line x from the get line x from
index here okay so i don't need to use
offset anymore here so what is the index
i have to pass here you can see that we
have to rework this and the minimum
index
should not be zero else we will see
lines only on the right but it should
start halfway of the number of lines for
example
if we have four lines we'll have minus
one
zero
one and two so we can compute this start
index
which will be here okay
start index is going to be the half of
number of lines i'm just going to put
int okay so if i have 4 i'm going to get
2 for the start index so i will put
minus two but in that case you see that
we don't start at minus two we start at
minus one so i need to put plus one for
my start index and what is my end index
and the index is going to be the start
index plus the number of lines so for
example here the start index is minus
one the number of lines is four minus
one equals three so i will get three for
this value here but that's correct
because in the range we will never reach
3 for the i we will reach 2. so we will
have this it's going to work if we give
from index
i let's try it ok so it is still working
fine i just want to simplify a bit the
program here i want to go to the
transform and enable the 2d transform
so we can really see what we are doing
here and also we are going to disable
any movement so i'm going to comment the
offset y
and the offset x in the update function
just for the time that we are working on
the coordinates for the tiles and also i
will put less vertical lines i will put
four vertical lines and zero dot one for
the spacing okay so now i have something
like this it's correct and also i can
update the update horizontal lines
because we copy paste what we did
previously on the update vertical lines
so we can delete that
and we are going to compute x min and x
max from the new function self dot
get line x from index okay the start
index we have it
it's this value the line totally on the
left okay so i can put start index here
and for the end index and index
it's going to be the start index plus
number of lines so for example i have
number of lines four start index is
minus one so it's going to be three but
the maximum index i want here is two so
i need to put minus one in this case so
i have my end index here okay i can
restart my program and everything is
working fine
for this exercise you are going to
implement this function get line y from
index so if i give index 0 is going to
return 0 if i give index 1 is going to
be spacing y and then index 2 is going
to be the y value for this line etc okay
and so on don't forget to use the
current offset y and also you will need
to rework the update horizontal line
function to use your new function i let
you practice on your side and then i
will show you the solution
[Music]
just below this function i'm going to
implement the new function get line y
from index okay if i go to update
horizontal lines you can see that we
have here's spacing y and that we have
already this computation of the line y
so i'm just going to copy
these lines and that i'm going to paste
that okay spacing y equal
h line spacing set the distance between
two horizontal lines that's correct
multiply by the height okay i'm going to
delete four
and then the line y is the index
multiplied by the spacing
okay if we have index zero we will start
from 0 minus the current of set y you
remember that this is offset that we use
so that we have this illusion that we go
forward into the game and then i return
a line y now i'm going to use this
function from the
update horizontal lines i will replace
this line of code with self dot get line
wind and i will pass the index i don't
need the spacing y anymore so i can just
clean it from the code let's start the
program to see if it is working well
everything is correct and that's all for
the exercise
let's display our first tile how can we
do that for example if you want to
display the tile 0 we need to first
implement this and get tile coordinates
function so we can get lower left
coordinate x min and y min if we pass to
this function
plus one and plus one you are going to
get the x max and y max so it's going to
be easy to be able to display this tile
concerning the canvas are we going to
display this with a rectangle not really
because in the perspective mode we will
need to display something like this so
we will need to give four coordinates
and for that we are going to use the
quad it's not possible with a rectangle
because the rectangle use a width and a
height only here with the quad we will
give 4 points how does the quad works so
we have our x mean y min that we get
from the get type coordinates zero in
that case
if you want to get the x max y max we
get it from
plus one and plus one okay you can see
that we have also two other points x min
and y max and x max and y min we need to
give the four points to the quad so the
quad will get a points list in which
orders we need to give the points that's
up to us but we need to rotate in a way
or in the other way but we cannot go
from that point to this one or something
like this we need to take a point and
rotate so in our case this will be point
number one number two number three and
number four so at first we will put x
min y min then this one and then x max y
min of course we will need to call our
transform function at the last moment
that means we will need to use
intermediate variable like x1 and y1 so
x1 y1 will be the transformation of
x-min and y-min and so on let's
implement this and display our first
style so first thing i'm going to do is
to implement this get tile coordinates
function so if i go just below that i'm
going to write def
get
tile
coordinate
and it will take the tile index x and
tile index y i need to return the x and
y of the tile so x is going to be
finally
the get line x from the index t i x
and the y it's going to be the get line
y from the tile index y and we need to
return this okay for this first example
we are going to display only one tile
but of course in the game we will need
to display multiple tiles so let's just
define only one tile for now so i'm just
going to write tile equal none and we
are going to give the coordinates here t
i x equals zero of course we will change
that later so we can check if the
different positions are working well
okay then i will do the same principle
as a vertical and horizontal line i will
have a init function
so self init tiles and i will have an
update function for initials i'm going
to copy paste the init vertical lines
function
so it's going to be init
tiles and i don't need to do that okay i
will display it as white it's correct
and here i will do my self
tile it's going to be the quad so i just
write quad and i need to import it okay
then i will do my update function so i
go a little bit downstairs update tiles
of course i will need to call this
function in the update function so i
will just do it right now self not
update tiles okay i go back here i want
first to get my x min
and y min how can i get this i can call
self dot and get tile coordinates and i
can give the coordinates of my tile t i
x and t i y
ok also i can get the x max and y max
by putting a plus 1 and plus one in the
index now i want to give the points to
my tile to my quad so it's going to be
points equal and i'm going to give the
list of points i'm going to have here x1
y1 then x2 y2 then x3 y3 and 4 okay so i
need to compute all of this
x1 y1 it's self dot transform and you
remember that
the first point i'm going to put a
command here is going to be the one at
the bottom left and then the second one
is at top left and then we get third
point and the fourth point so this one
it's x min and y min i'm going to copy
paste this line for three times so we
have
two two three
and four okay
point number two x min y max
it's upstairs point number three x max
y max and point number four x
max y min okay so i will give all of
this
let's try it and see what it gives okay
my tile at 0 is displayed here that's
correct let's change the coordinates so
if i go here i will give x equal 1 for
example okay we can see it's correct
it's displayed at one and zero and i'm
going to display at one two okay one two
it's correct let's go in the perspective
mode to see if it is still good okay i
can see it's still one two everything is
correct and we move on to the next
lecture
we are able to display our tile
correctly now if i enable the animation
again is it still working correctly so
let's try it i go back to my update
function and here i will enable the y
current of set y and here i will
uncomment this line with a current
offset y okay we can keep this line
commented for now but here we will go
forward into the level and also i will
change a bit the speed here i want to
have a speed only of one so we can see
what's really happening let's try it you
can see that my tile is going back after
a moment every time we loop every time
the line is coming here at the bottom of
the screen we have this loop effect and
this is because you remember in the
update function we have this looping
mechanism so the horizontal lines of the
level are always displayed when we reach
the spacing between two lines we go back
to the initial position
and in fact the position of my tile is
always correct it's always 0 x and 2 for
the y so how can we make the tile going
forward every time we loop we need to
remember that we loop so we will have a
loop index that we will call the current
y loop and it's going to be plus equal
one i'm going to declare this variable
so here current
while loop equal zero okay so you can
see that if i add a print
loop and i can display
the value of this loop and i can put it
on the screen okay so you see every time
we loop the tile go back in the screen
so what we are going to do is every time
we loop we are going to change the index
of the tile on the y axis initially our
tile is on index 2 for the y but then
when we will first look it's going to go
to index 1 then index 0 and so on
so we need to subtract the index of our
tile from the current loop we already
have a function that returns the
coordinates of the tile it's get tile
coordinates so i can look at this
variable inside this function and we
will use it to offset
the index of the tile t i y equal t i y
minus the current y loop so the first
time we will loop with the loop we'll
have a value of one then we offset the
index so here we do the index minus one
so the tile will not jump again but
we'll go to the next line let's start
the program again and you can see that
this time every time i loop my tile is
evolving in the level and it's working
perfectly
let's write some code to display
multiple tiles how can we do that we
need to change this part of code because
here we manage only one tile and we put
some coordinates here so we are going to
change that and to have a collection of
tiles with a list here so tiles is going
to be the list of the quads and we also
need to have the number of tiles for
example four tiles and also we need to
remove these coordinates because the
different types will have different
coordinates so we need to have a list of
coordinates tiles coordinates
okay we will write a new function to
generate the tile coordinates but at
first it's going to be a very simple
generation i want to generate the tiles
in the middle of the screen so the first
tile will be at 0
then the second one will be at
0 1
0 2
and so on it's going to be a straight
line in the middle and of course later
we will change that generation function
so that we can generate the length of
the game okay so let's write the code
first i need to change my init function
because i need to loop on n beta tiles
to initialize the different quads so i
go to inside any tiles i need to loop
here so for
i in range
zero to self ambitize i will create quad
but i will add it in my tiles list tiles
append quad okay and i need to be inside
the loop of course we will need to
rework the update function because we
need to use the tile coordinates but
first let's generate the tile
coordinates i will write a new function
f g narrate
tiles coordinates i will use the same
loop on the number of tiles and inside
the tile coordinates i will append some
coordinates inside this list i need to
append some tuples so inside the
parenthesis i'm going to add more
parenthesis for this first generation
it's going to be very simple
all the x index is 0 and the y index is
going to be i
so the first tile will be at 0 then the
next one at 0 1 0 2 ok to build this
straight line of course i need to call
this function at the beginning so i'm
going to copy that and to paste it here
self dot generate tiles coordinates okay
just below initials next thing we need
to do is to adapt the update function
update tiles previously we use this
variable t i x and t i y now we need to
loop and update the points for every
tile so again i need to loop on i
in range 0 to nb tiles okay and i will
put everything
inside the loop my coordinates are in
self
tie coordinates of i and you remember
what we did we put a tuple for each tile
that means for each coordinate the index
0 is x and the index 1 is a y index t i
x t i y so in my tuple here i will call
it
tile coordinate local variable and here
i will get the x from the index 0 of my
tuple and the y from the index 1 of my
tuple and to get the x max and y max i
will do the same
plus one okay now i need to update the
tile so it's going to be in the tiles i
can do the same as here i will say that
my tile is a self dot tiles at index
okay so tile dot points equal all the
points let's try it okay so you can see
i have four tiles displayed in a
straight line and of course i can change
the number of tiles for example i can
put eight
and it's going to generate more tiles
everything is working correctly and
let's move on to the next video
let's improve this function to generate
infinite tiles so now we are just going
to keep the straight line but you can
see that after a moment the straight
line disappears because we have a
limited number of ties so what we are
going to do is that all the tiles that
are no more visible that are out of the
screen we are going to clean them from
the tile coordinates and that will make
new space to add new coordinates that we
will add after so we will make a
mechanism to generate new tiles on the
fly for example here if i reduce the
number of tiles to 4 and when we will
implement this solution
you will see that new tiles will appear
after each loop so we will generate this
straight line an infinite way how can we
do that you remember that in the update
function we have this loop indicator so
we will compare
does the tie index y is less than this
loop then we will clean it from the
coordinates and of course we will need
to call our generation function each
time we change this variable now the
generation function has been done in a
way we should only call it at one time
in the init but we will change it so we
can call it in the update function every
time we increment the loop so first
thing we are going to do is to clean
the coordinates
that are out of the screen and the
condition is at the tile index y so this
is what we have in the tile coordinates
at one and the condition is that the
tile index y is going to be less than
the self
current y loop okay when i increment
this variable it means that the tile
that was at 0 is already out of the
screen so at the next call of this
function we are going to clean it let's
implement that and then we will debug to
see if it is working correctly so we are
going to loop on this style coordinates
and because we are going to delete some
elements inside this list we are going
to start from the end
so i will write 4
i in
range what is the end is the
number
of elements in the list
minus 1 else we will be out of the list
okay and then i will put -1 here because
i want to decrement i will start from
the maximum value and go to the minimum
value but for the minimum value we also
want to go to the zero index and because
in the range we will never reach the
zero here we need to put a minus one so
that we can reach zero okay the
condition is that if
tile coordinates at the index
and we select the y
it's less
than the current y loop then it
disappears it's out of the screen so in
that case
we will just delete it okay and because
we will call this function again and
again we should not start from zero
every time and happen many coordinates
we should look how much space we have
left in the tile coordinate so we are
going to start not from zero but from
the number of elements okay of course
the first time it will be zero so first
time we will fill everything and i'm
going to put a print full so we can have
a breakpoint here and we will see what
happens of course this function we need
to call it again every time the current
while loop change
so it's going to be called one time at
the beginning to generate the first four
coordinates here this code will not do
anything because at first current while
loop is zero and of course we don't have
any elements in tile coordinates
so we are not going to do anything here
but here the length of type coordinate
is zero so we will happen all the
elements at the first call then for the
next call we will see what happens so i
will need to call it in the update
function just after we have updated the
current while loop generate tile
coordinates okay
let's have a look
and let's put a break point i will have
foo one and four two through one
just after the deletion of the elements
and foot okay
so let's have a look at what we have in
self tile coordinates at the beginning
we don't have anything okay if i press
continue then we generate the elements
and we have our four elements zero one
zero two zero three it's correct and we
have the current while loop which is
zero then i will continue the execution
we enter the function again we did our
clean with current while loop equal to
one
so now what we have in the list is only
three elements because we remove the
zero in the y is less than current while
loop which is now one okay but now
what's happening we want to generate a
new element because we have one space so
we want to add a zero four and look what
will happen here if i step
i'm going to add one element because i
have the space to add one element but
i'm going to add the element at the
index
i which is not the right value which is
3. so here i will add again the same
tile and what i need to do is to have
another variable which is going to be
the last y so we are going to look in
the list what was the last element and
we are going to take its y which is 3 in
that case and add a plus one and then we
will add the zero four and every time
we'll take the last one and make a plus
one so we can continue the generation
this way so let's do that let's say that
at first
the last y is zero when we start and
when we don't have any elements it's
going to be zero that's what i'm going
to use here instead of the index and of
course i need to use last y plus equal
one okay
but that's not enough for the first time
it's going to work and when we remove
one element and in that case it means in
that case we want to take the last
element and takes its y value plus one
so let's do that if we have some
elements if the length of tile
coordinates isn't greater than zero then
we are going to take the last
coordinates which is in python at the
index minus one okay and last coordinate
is going to have the x value
and the y value and we are going to take
its y value in the last y but of course
we need to add a plus
one so that we can generate
next tile okay let's put again the
breakpoints and try it okay again the
first time we did not generate anything
yet tile coordinate has nothing i press
continue then i generate my first tiles
okay let's continue
this time i clean the first one and i
got the last y which is four because i
took the value three plus one so i get
four and now if i step i'm going to add
the zero four
and then next time it will be the zero
five zero six so i will have an infinite
line
let's continue the execution and you can
see that the way is generated
automatically and infinitely
let's generate the land for our game and
we want to generate a random path now we
just generate a straight line but we
want something that goes on the left or
that goes on the right so how can we do
that for example if i get a random
number and if i say okay we always get a
x of zero but if you want to go on the
left we'll get x of minus one or plus
one so let's try to get a random number
that is between minus one and plus one
if i type
r like random equal
random dot
round int you need to import
random this one we will put the minimum
value of minus one and the maximum of
plus one both value can be returned in
the result it's included okay so i will
put this value as a r and let's see what
it gives you can see that i have a kind
of land generation but we don't get
really a pass so it's not going to work
well with a ship because for example we
cannot go from here to here it's going
to be a game over and of course we need
to share more than just a corner between
some tiles so we will need to add some
more tiles to make a real pass so for
example what we can do is to choose what
we want to do for example go forward
it's going to be
this first choice just to add the tile
and that's what we are doing here if we
go on the right it's going to be
this style that we use to go for one the
same one then a next style on the right
and then a next style forward so it's
going to be
this pattern okay and then we can
continue and if you want to go on the
left we generate one tile forward as
usual
and then one tile on the left and then
one tile forward so we will have also
this pattern what we are going to do is
to get a random number 0 1 or 2 and
depending on the value of this random
number we will generate a different
pattern in the coordinates but you can
see that for every pattern we still need
to generate the next tile the one that
goes forward it is common to all
patterns in the case we go on the right
we'll generate this style on the x and y
then on the x plus one and y
and then on the x plus one and y plus
one okay and so on so let's do it let's
say that when we go forward it will be
zero when we go on the right it will be
one and on the left it will be two so
let's implement this solution i'm going
to get a random number between
0 and
2. in all case i will need to generate
and that one of course it's not r it's
the last x we need to manage the last
value of the x to continue the pass so
in the same way that we have the last y
i'm going to have my last x equal 0 and
we will also get it from the last tile
last x is going to be we don't need to
use plus one for this one because we
keep the same x and
we put zero to get the x coordinate okay
now i want to test if
r equal one i will go on the right let's
put a command here so let's say that 0
is
straight that 1 is on the right and that
2 is the left
so if r equal 1 then we need to generate
a next tile and that will be just on its
right you remember the pattern it's like
this we have the tile then we have this
next style close to it and on top of
that we will have the next one so i need
to get the last x
plus equal one and then i will need to
generate the one that goes forward so i
will need to have the last y plus equal
one and
generate my tile okay in the case of r
equal to i do a last x is
minus one and i will do the same thing
so let's start let's try it okay i have
a land generation it's quite slow and
also what i want to say is that
previously is that in this loop
we look how much space we have in this
tile coordinate for example if we
already have three coordinates and we
have a maximum number of tile of four we
will have only one space but before we
used to only open one tile in every loop
now it can happen we add three tiles and
that we go above the number of tiles but
it's okay we will just have more
coordinates here than the number of
tiles but anyway when the old
coordinates the one out of the screen
will be cleaned we will make more space
and because we check the length of tile
coordinates yes it will happen that this
value will be sometime greater than the
number of tiles but it's okay because on
the update function we just loop on the
number of tiles and we will just ignore
the extra coordinates so we can do that
but we need to speed up a bit the game
and
let's say we put four and also because
we need to display more tiles i'm going
to put for example eight here okay so
now we have really a land generation
which is interesting because we have a
pass of course we have this effect of
generation so if you don't want this
effect you add more tiles for example 16
and this time you will not see the
generation because it's going to be done
very far so we have two issues because
you can see that the land generation can
go totally out of the track so we need
to solve that and also when we just
start the program it will be nice to
have first a straight line and after
begin the land generation else it's
going to be too difficult for the player
also i want to try by enabling again the
keys so i'm going to uncomment
this line to be able to go on the left
and on the right to see if everything is
working well okay i can go on the left
and on the right we really have a
beginning of game here that's all for
this video and let's continue on the
project
you can see that the land generation can
go out of the grid here and i'm going to
ask you for this exercise to make it
impossible but first let's change a bit
the parameters because the grid with
only four vertical lines is not
interesting for the game so we'll put
eight and we will put more spacing dot
okay let's try it again so you can see
that sometimes the land generation goes
here out of the grid and i want you to
solve this problem how to solve this you
remember that in a function on the
update
horizontal lines we have this start
index variable and end index it gives
the index of the line totally on the
left and the line totally on the right
so you will take these two lines you
will copy that in the land generation
and you will compare to your last x
if your last x is already less or equal
to the start index then you will need to
go on the right because you are already
too much on the left and to go on the
right you will force the value of the
random value you will not take the
random value but you will override it to
go on the right
and here you will do the same to go on
the left i let you do the exercise and
then i will show you the solution
[Music]
so first thing i will do is to take
these two lines and go back to the land
generation in the generate tiles
coordinates when i get the random value
here i will first have a look okay does
my
last x
is less or equal than the start index
that means i'm already totally on the
left and in that case i will not take
this random value
but i will say
go on the right so i will force the
value of one on the other side if my
last x
is greater or equal
than the end index that means i'm too
much on the right i will go back on the
left so i will give value two let's try
it okay you can see that here i reached
the maximum but i did not go over
and you will see that even if you wait
for a while you will never go out of the
grid and that's all for this exercise
we are going to improve our game by
adding first a straight line and after a
moment we will really begin the
generation of the pass as it's going to
be too difficult for the player if we
start directly with a pattern so you
will add this straight line of 10 tiles
and after that you will begin the
generation for this you are going to
create a new function
that i will call
pre fill tiles coordinate
okay you will implement this function
and you will add 10 tiles in a straight
line of course i need to call this
function we will call this function only
one time in the init and just before the
generate tiles coordinate i let you do
the exercise and then i will show you
the solution
[Music]
so here i will loop
for i in range
0 to 10 and i will add some coordinates
in self tile coordinates at the
beginning this list is empty so i will
just append some coordinates inside i
need to put my tuple so it's going to be
parenthesis inside parentheses because
it's a straight line in the center we
use 0 for x and we use i for the range
and we use i for the y so here i will
get 0 1 until 0 9 straight line and
after that we will get some code to
generate tile coordinates at first it
will not generate anything because we
already have too much coordinates we are
already over the number of tiles but
after a moment it will remove some
coordinates that are no more displayed
on the screen and when we will have more
space then we will begin to generate new
tiles let's try it
you can see i have my straight line and
after moment i can begin to play
everything is correct for this exercise
and let's continue on the project
let's display our spaceship on the
screen the spaceship is going to be a
triangle and we will place it at the
bottom and center horizontally of the
screen self.width divided by two we will
define new variables to define the width
of the ship in a percentage of the
screen width also the height and also
the base y so that it is not totally at
the bottom of the screen concerning the
canvas we are going to use the triangle
instruction we will need three points
point number one number two and number
three for this exercise you are going to
implement the coordinates of these three
points for the ship and to add it in the
new ship variable that will be our
triangle instruction first we will write
some code together and then you will do
the exercise i'm going to define the new
variables so i go at the top of the main
widget and here i will create the new
ship variable that is unknown and that
will contain the triangle instructions
so we will need to create an init ship
function also i will define the ship
width that is going to be 10 percent of
the screen so i give you some values
that i tested previously that makes the
display nice but you can change them of
course ship hate which is 0.035
and chip base y equal
0.04 okay let's create the init ship
function in it ship we want to use the
canvas and this time we are not going to
use a white color because the ship will
be displayed in black so we will put
zero and of course we want to create our
triangle instruction and this is going
to be saved in our ship variable and we
need to import that okay now we need
also to create the update function so
you may say yes but the ship is not
moving it's in the land which is moving
yes but the ship is displayed at the
middle of the screen because we can
resize the window the middle of the
screen may change so we need to update
the coordinates of the ship dev update
ship and this is what you will need to
do for this exercise you will need to
compute the coordinates and at the end
you will do self.ship not points equal
x1 y1 x2 y2 x3
y3 and you need to give this different
value x1 equal something from the slide
you remember that point number one is
lowest left and point number two is here
at the center and then we have point
number three don't forget to use the
transform function because here we
display on the screen so you will need
to call this self transform to help you
i'm going to give you some intermediate
variable center x
is a self dot width divided by two base
y which is a y coordinate for the point
one and point three it's going to be
self dot
ship base y multiplied by seven hate and
again we don't give pixel dimensions for
the ship because if the screen is bigger
then the ship will look very small so we
need to give percentage on the width and
the height of the screen you can also
have the ship widths which is going to
be self dot
sheep weeds multiply by self width but
in fact what is going to be interesting
for you here is to have the half of the
weeds so we will write ship half
width and we are going to divide this by
two it's time for you to do this
exercise and then i will show you the
solution
[Music]
so we may write x1 equal center x
minus the half width of the ship okay
and then we will have y1 equal the base
y but take care because we need to call
the transform function so what we need
to do here is to call it from here
transform and so i'm going to give the x
coordinate and the y coordinate okay so
i can do the same for the other points
i'm going to copy paste this x2 y2
x3
y3 for x2 it is at the center x and for
the height we take base y and we need to
compute the height of the ship so it's
going to be ship height equal self ship
height multiply by self hate so it's
going to be base y plus ship height
and for the last one it's going to be
the same as the first one but we do a
plus on the half width let's try it we
see it's not displayed and why it is not
displayed because we did not call our
functions and let's call the init
function should we call our init ship
function before the initials or afters
initialize in fact it is very important
because if we call it before the ship is
going to be displayed under the path
because the order of instructions
matters here so we need to display the
ship after any tiles so the ship is
above the pass self
not in it ship
also we need to call the update function
update ship that we will call in the
update function here just after update
tiles
self dot update ship okay let's try it
you see that this time it's working we
have the ship displayed of course we
will need to adjust all the speed of the
game because now it's not really
playable but that's it for the exercise
and let's continue
maybe you saw that we have a big issue
in our game look if i start it
if i resize the window especially if the
window is very small the game is faster
and if i get the window bigger
the game is very slow so why do we have
this problem for this exercise i'm going
to ask you to investigate and fix this
issue i give you one hint it's not a
problem of performance it's really a
problem in our code so try to
investigate and at least try to find
where does it come from and then try to
fix this problem so that the speed is
constant
when we resize the window practice on
your side and then i will show you the
solution
[Music]
so clearly why do we have a difference
when we change the size of the window
and what defines the speed of our game
the speed of the game is defined by this
variable speed which is the speed on the
y axis
and also the speed x on the x axis so
for example here we have a speed of 4
where do we use it we use it every time
in the update function here it means
that every time we display a frame of
the game we increment our y by this
constant value and also we multiply it
by the time factor but this is okay so
why is there a problem here because we
have a constant value for the speed of 4
in this case and 4 is a very big value
for a small screen that means for a
small screen we increment the y of 4
every time but 4 is a very small value
for a big screen so that's why we have a
difference here it's because the speed
does not depends on the
size of the window and that's what we
are going to change we need to make the
speed depend on the size of the window
because we see the speed on the y-axis
we need to multiply it by the height of
the window
so let's do that we are going to define
a new variable speed y equal to the
speed multiplied by self hate and you
may say yes but
4 multiplied by the height of the screen
it's a big value yes of course we need
to adjust the value of the speed
variable and we will need to put
something very small so let's take this
and multiply by time factor okay we have
to do the same for the x
so speed x is going to be the current
speed x and you remember that current
speed x is in fact speed x but it
depends sometime it's speed x or
sometimes it's zero depending on if we
press on a key or not so it's going to
be current speed x multiplied by self
width okay so now i go back upstairs and
i'm going to put a very small value
here and see what it gives okay so for
the y it's going quite quickly and for
the x it's a bit small also what we can
do here is that we can multiply by 100
so we will have 1 and 1. it's going to
be more relevant value so what we can do
in the formula downstairs is to divide
by 100 speed y divided by 100 and speed
x
divided by 100 that means my
value here has to be multiplied by 100
so i have one dot zero i said that the
speed on the y axis is a bit high so i'm
going to put a smaller
value dot 8 and for the x we need more
speed 3 for example let's try it and
let's expand a bit the width of the
tiles dot 4. okay so we have something
like this you can see i can clearly play
in the game it's a bit difficult but i
can't play it can i still play it if the
window is smaller you can see that the
speed is still the same and i can
continue to play my game okay if i
expand the window it's going to be also
the same speed so we fixed our problem
and that's all for the exercise
let's detect that the ship is still on
the track and if that's not the case it
will be game over at first we will just
print game over to know that the ship is
still on the track we will say that at
least one of the three points of the
triangle is going to collide with one of
the tiles i'm just going to put a very
small speed for
x and y
and to show you what it gives in 2d so
let's go back in two dimension and let's
start the program okay we'll also reduce
spacing here between the vertical lines
okay we have something like this and
what we want to do is to look at the
three points of the triangle if at least
one point is still on the track it's
okay but if the three points are out of
the track it's going to be a game over
but now we are going to print in a loop
game over and later we will implement a
proper game over so do we need to test
all the tile no we just need to test the
tiles that are at the bottom of the
screen because the spaceship is always
at the bottom of the screen so we will
just test the first two ranks here that
are defined by the current y loop so
we'll test current while loop plus one
and of course if at least one of the
tile makes a collision what i call a
collision is when one of the three
points is contained on a tile at least
only one tile is needed to say it's okay
we are still on the track so let's do
that and first we will implement a
function to test if the spaceship is
colliding with
one tile and after that we will make
another function to make the test for
different tiles okay so i will just
write my function just under the update
chip and it's going to be def check
ship collision with tile and i will give
the tile index x and tile index y you
remember that we can get the tile
coordinates from this function self
get tile coordinates and i give the i x
and t i y and i will get so
x min and y min and if i want to get the
max i can just add plus one so i'm going
to do like this
plus one and plus one okay so now i want
to get the coordinates of the spaceship
and we have three points so i need to
get a new variable to store the
different points of the ship and we are
going to call that ship
coordinates
equal and it's going to be a list of
three points that i will initialize here
first point second point and third point
ship coordinates where do we have the
ship coordinates in the update function
here so we are going to change the bit
what we do here to store the different
coordinates and of course we want to get
the coordinates before the transform
after the transform is just for the
display but before the transform is for
the logic and of course the coordinate
we get for the tile are before the
transform very important so here what we
will do is save that ship coordinates
for the first point
we want this tuple containing this value
for the y and because we don't want to
do a copy paste of the same code i'm
going to use this value
here
now if i copy that it's not going to
work like that because the transform
function needs two arguments x and y and
this is seen as only one argument
containing a tuple as one argument which
is a tuple so we need to expand the
tuple so i will put a star and this is
going to put directly this first
argument and this second argument okay
let's do the same for the two other
points
one and two this one is center x and
base y plus the height
and the last one is the same but just a
plus on the x okay so let's copy paste
all of this
and we do one and two so check that your
index are correct here okay
so now we have all three points in ship
coordinates and i'm going to loop for
these different points for i in range
0 to 3 i will loop on ship coordinates
of index and i will get the point x and
point y now i need to see
does my point is inside this tile
so i can check if it is contained and if
that's the case i will return true and i
will say okay we are colliding i just
need at least one point that is
colliding when it's the case i will just
exit the function and return true but if
we loop for all the points and we did
not collide with anything we will return
false so how can i test that my x must
be contained between x min and x max so
i'm going to write my point x must be
greater than the x mean and it should be
lower or equal than the x max also i can
simplify this expression to write it
like this my point x is between x min
and x max included and
we are going to have the same for the py
is contained in y min and y max
if that's the case we return true yes we
are inside this style and we are not
going to continue the loop even if
that's the case for the first point
the function returns true and we exit
the function here okay if that was not
the case we continue to the next point
and the next point and if that was not
the case for every point
we will return false okay now we want to
do that but for
all the tiles that are on the two first
rank so we can write our function
check
ship call lesia ok this function will
return true if the ship is on the track
and it will return false if that's not
the case in that case we will say game
over where are the tile coordinates it's
in self
tile coordinates okay so what i can do
is to loop
on these coordinates in range
0 to length of this
but i told you we are not going to test
all the tiles it's not necessary so we
will add an exit condition here but
first let's get our tile index x
and tile index y from the tile
coordinates at index okay i get my tile
what is the exit condition if my tile
index y
is greater
than the current while loop plus one it
means i don't need to test the tiles
that are above the first two ranks
because the ship is always at the bottom
of the screen anyway so this will avoid
that we do unnecessary tests if my tile
index y is greater than the self current
while loop plus one because i want to
test the first two ranks of ties if
that's the case i will say that
i return false i could not return 1
because i did not return true because it
means i did not return true on the
previous tiles the types that are in the
first two ranks now i will check my tile
if check ship collision with the tile
that we want to test here if we have a
collision then it's okay everything is
finished we return true that's okay we
are still on the track but if we loop
and we test all the tiles and we go
after the first two ranks
and then the story is finished or if we
go at the end of the function
it means we did not collide and that's a
return false let's call this function on
the update function so we go to the
bottom of the code in the update
function and then i will call this rdn
self
check ship collision if
not
if we return false in this function that
means we are in a game over conditions
so for now we will just print
game over okay let's try it okay you can
see i'm on the track everything is fine
here i am still on the track because i
have two points colliding still here i
have still one point colliding but if i
go totally out we can see game over okay
if i go back it's still working fine so
let's go back in perspective mode to see
that everything is okay
transform i go in perspective mode and
i'm going to put back some
better value here so line spacing 0.4
and speed x little bit greater for
example 3 let's try that it's far too
slow i'm going to have point 8
so now you can see it's good and when i
go out of the track we can see in game
over here okay everything is correct and
let's move on to the next lecture
[Music]
galaxy project version number three our
project will look like this we will have
a menu we will be able to start the
project to play
and to go into the game over also we
have the score that is displayed here in
this version we will first manage the
game states the game will not start by
itself but we will press the button to
start the game and also when we will
have a game over the game will stop we
will display this menu that will be
displayed when we start the game and
also when we get into the game over and
we will finalize by displaying the
background image by playing the
different sounds and also displaying the
score and i will finish on that project
by sharing with you my different ideas
and how to improve this game are you
ready to start let's do it
let's add a game over state to our game
now we detect the game over but we still
continue to play for example here we
display game over in the trace but we
can still continue we want to stop the
game when we get a game over so we are
going to add a new variable that i call
the
state
game over and as a default our game is
not in game over but when i will have no
collision with the tiles i will go in
game over mod
self not stay game over equal to also i
want to print this trace only one time
so i will test if no collisions okay and
we were not
in a game over already okay so this will
be executed only one time also i want to
stop the game so if we are in a game
over mode we are going to stop doing few
things in the update function for
example here we continue to go forward
in the game so we are going to do that
if not game over if you are in game over
we will stop going forward into the game
also i want to stop doing the loop
because anyway we don't move into the
game anymore and also i want to remove
the possibility to go on the left and on
the right so all of this block is under
this condition when we are in game over
all of this will be disabled let's try
it
so you can see i can play
but as soon as i go out of the track the
game is freezed and i can see game over
so it seems it's working well but i'm
going to show you a small case where
it's not really working well it's
especially if we put very high speed
here for example two and you will see
what happened here i just start the game
you can see i'm not in a game over but
you can see that the game is freezed
already and if i look you can see i got
a game over so why does i have a game
over while i'm not in a game over
condition this is because when we start
our game here we go in the init and we
prepare many things we initialize all of
this and at the end we do the clock
schedule to call the update function in
fact kivy did not finish to initialize
everything he need to initialize the
screen and many other things so the call
to the update function is going to take
more time than expected at the beginning
and so for the first calls we are going
to have a big delta time here look if i
enable again the trace of the delta time
you can see here in the trace that
normally we should have something around
1
and that's mostly the case except at the
beginning if you look the first delta
time is very high 29 it's because kv was
starting so it took more time than
expected but in our case what happened
we took that delta time and then we
compute our time factor from the time
factor we used it in the computation of
the current of set y so we made a big
step in one time and because of this we
were a bit ahead of the computation of
the loop because in the condition we
check if this current offset y is
greater than the spacing y and in that
case yes we increment the loop and we
remove spacing y
but what happened here is that because
of the big value that we put at once we
were far greater than the spacing y even
greater than two times or three times
the spacing y and so normally we should
be in the current while loop of maybe
three or four but we just increment by
one and so in the computation of the
check ship collision we are going to
compare the collision with tiles that
are already out of the screen and that's
why we don't get any collision and that
we get a game over directly so the bug
is here in this condition in fact we
should do that as much as we need and
that's why you should replace it with a
while current offset is greater than
spacing y we will subtract it and we
will increment the loop okay let's start
the program again you could see i got a
game over but it is a real game over
this time because it was very quick
so i'm going to comment this trace and
i'm going to reduce a bit and the speed
to 0.8 okay so this time everything is
working fine
we want to improve our game by adding a
menu so that we have a button to start
the game and not having this behavior of
the game that is starting automatically
okay so we will click to start the game
and when we will have a menu again to
restart the game the menu widget will be
very simple it's going to be a title a
button and have another lay that is
going to be a dark overlay and we are
going to use the same menu for the start
of the game and for the game over the
difference will be the title and the
text of the button that will be modified
so let's just create this menu we need
to create a new python file that we will
call menu and we will need also to
create the kv file menu
dot kv make sure that all the files are
here in the same directory in the menu
python file i will create
my menu widget and because you are going
to use all the screen size let's make a
relative layout so i don't need to
specify manually the size that would be
the case if it was a widget so i just
use a relative layout so i will also
change the main widget and take it from
a relative layout okay so now that we
have this we can define the menu widget
in rkv file so menu widget it's a
relative layout but i still call it
widget that's okay so what do we have
inside we have a label and we have a
button for the label i'm going to put a
text for the text we will do that later
so now i put title and for the button i
will put ok concerning the position i
want to put it in the center of the
screen so i will put
center
x
dot 5
and center y
i'm not going to put dot 5 because i
want to put the button just below so i
put it just a bit upstairs so i'm going
to put it at 60
0.6 and the button i will put it a
little bit downstairs at 1.4 okay so now
let's take this menu widget and let's
put it in our galaxy.kv i put it inside
my main widget here but you will see
that if i want to start my program right
now i have an error because you don't
know my new widget i am missing an
import statement here import menu okay
so now you can see the menu is not
displayed and that is because we have
the menu.kv file i need to say to kivy
to take this file into account so in the
main just before the main widget i will
write builder dot
load
file and it's going to be menu dot kv
okay i need to import this
kv long builder
let's try it
so you see the menu is appearing and the
button is very big so it's because we
did not specify any size for the button
so let's do that back to the menu.kv i'm
going to give a
size hint to my button and i will put
twenty percent horizontally and ten
percent vertically let's have a look so
you can see i have my title so the title
is in white so we cannot see it here but
we could show it a little bit and i have
my button another thing we want to do is
to put a black overlay almost black
overlay like 80
so we can still see the game but have
this darkened background when we have
the menu so we can do that in our
menu.kv in the canvas so i'm going to
write canvas
and i want to use this as the first
instruction so i will use canvas before
i will use color that is going to be
rgba so we have a black color zero and
for the alpha we are going to use eighty
percent this color i will use it with a
rectangle and it will take all the size
self.size okay let's try it
so now you can see that we have our menu
with a dark overlay in the next video we
will add the state to our game to avoid
starting the game directly and we will
also use the action on the button to
start the game and when we will have a
game over we will display the menu again
we are going to implement the first part
of the menu so we will start our game
only when we click on the ok button
and we will need also to hide the menu
in that case and of course we will need
to show the menu again when we are in
game over so let's add a new state so
that the game is not started directly we
will have
state
game
has
started and we are going to put
false
so when the game is not started we are
not going to do everything in the update
function like we do in the game over if
not game over we do that
and
self started and we should do it only if
the game has started that means if the
game has not started we are not going to
do anything here so if i start again you
can see that this time the game is not
starting automatically now i need to
manage the click on the button for the
button i can go to my menu and i can add
on press
event and i will create a function on
menu button
pressed okay we need to put the
parenthesis here because it's a call is
it going to be root dot on menu button
pressed not really because in that case
we want to define this function not in
the menu widget but inside the parent
inside the main widget directly so it's
going to be root dot parent dot on menu
button pressed and i'm going to define
this function in the main widget so i'm
going to go totally at the end of the
main widget
and i will create this function i will
just put a print
button okay so now is it working if i
start when i click the button i should
see my trace and you see that the button
is not working i don't see any button
trace and i don't see any lightning on
the button it's like the button doesn't
get any touch and why so it's because if
you look what we did in the main widget
in the user action we have this function
will manage the touch and if we put a
breakpoint here and if i restart
even when i click on the button we will
go into this function and the problem
that we have here is that this function
overrides the default behavior but will
not transmit the touch to the other
widget and this is because we did not
call the
super
and we need to call super with the type
main widget in our case
self dot
and untouched down and giving the touch
okay i'm just going to clean some traces
okay so now you will see that we are
going to have one issue because we need
main widgets you see but if we import it
user actions will need main widget but
main widget already needs user action so
we have a problem of mutual inclusions
so what we can do here is to give the
parent class of the main
widget is relative layout so you see
here the import from user actions is
here okay so we can take relative layout
and put it instead here in the super and
i will import the relative layout you
will see that this time when i start the
program i can click on the button and
when i click on the button i want to
start the game and to hide the menu so
let's do that
back in the main widget in my button
click i will start the game so i put my
self
state
has started to true but i also need to
hide the menu how can i hide the menu i
can use opacity equal zero the menu is
inside the main widget here and i need
to assign a property to it so i will use
id
menu widget
and i will need to create a new property
in the main widget okay i assign this
new property so we will need to define
it menu widget okay so now in the main
widget i go back to the top and i will
need to create
i will go here with other properties my
menu widget which is an object property
okay i need to import object property so
now that i have my menu widget
i can just use it in the click of the
button and i will do self dot menu
widget dot opacity equals zero let's try
it
so you can see that if i click the game
is starting but also you see it moved my
player
and okay after a while i get the game
over and so we have two issues first
when i click on the button also the main
widget is taking the click on the window
to move on the right or on the left so
we need to change that and when we have
the game over we need to display the
menu again so why we have this first
issue it's because on the user actions
on touchdown we should do that only
when we are in the right state and if
you remember we have two states here
game over and game has started that
means we want to do that only when we
are not in game over i'm going to
comment that
so if i'm not in
game over i can allow to
do the touch actions and
also that the game has started i can do
that okay first thing second thing we
need to change
is from the game over
so but before that i want to show you
the other thing we need to change is to
display the menu again when we have the
game over but i want to show you another
issue that we have so this time you see
that i can start and it's not moving
okay it's correct and okay i will lose
so now i'm in the game over but you see
that if i still click here even if the
menu is not displayed i still get my
button action and this is going to be a
problem on mobile when we are playing
and pressing the screen it may trigger
the action of the button and why is this
because we just use opacity on the menu
but the menu is still here and the
button is still here but not visible so
we need to handle that and what we can
do is that in the untouched buttons on
the on touchdown so i'm going to copy
this
function and i'm going to manage that on
the menu and i will say to the menu so
i'm going to delete all of this i will
say that when we touch something on the
menu and if the menu
if self opacity is equal to zero
we are not going to do anything with the
touch so i'm just going to return false
okay if the menu is not visible we
ignore the touch else we transmit the
touch
okay let's try that again okay i start
here i click again on the button but you
see that we don't have this button trace
so this is correct now i need to manage
the game over when we are in a game over
i want to show the menu again so i will
put opacity to one i copy this and here
in the game over
state i'm also going to put my menu back
visible okay so let's see i start
okay and i'm going to lose and then i
have the menu again and the next step we
need to implement is to be able to
restart the game from the top when we
click on the button and that's what we
are going to do next
we would like to be able to reset our
game here when we start our game okay
and when we have a game over when we
click it's not restarting the game
correctly so we need to develop
something to restart from zero and it's
going to be a reset function so i'm
going to add
this reset game function so we need to
define it so we will reset the game to
zero and we will put the right state and
remove the menu let's define this new
function so i'm going to go
just below the init here of the main
widget and i will put def
reset game in a reset game of course we
need to reset the state of the main
widget so it will concern all the
variables that we have here and of
course i will need to put game over to
false
game self.gameover equal false but you
will do that at the end of the function
because you remember that clock schedule
interval is running so the fact that we
are in game over equal to our game has
not started it will prevent from
executing this part of code so let's
keep this part of code disabled and we
will enable it again at the end by
putting game over equal false because
here we will reset different variables
so let's do that
what do we need to reset ship
coordinates it's okay because it's going
to be recomputed in the update the ship
has been initialized so we don't touch
it style coordinates we need to reset
tile coordinates because we need to
start with a straight line
so we want to put self tile coordinates
equal
an empty list and we will need to call
the prefill tile coordinates so we will
restart from a straight line and also we
will need to generate
the tile coordinates at the beginning
okay i continue
so tiles it's okay has been initialized
so we keep it but concerning the speed
here current offset y current offset one
is our y position so we need to reset it
to go back at the beginning of the game
and current while loop also and it's
going to be the same for the x variables
here we need to start with a speed of
zero and to be in the center of the
screen so let's copy all of this and i
will put a zero for all these variables
okay self current while loop i will
remove this one and i put everything to
zero what else do we have horizontal
line okay it has been initialized we
don't need to touch it vertical lines
also and perspective point and menu
widget okay so all of this we don't
touch it so we reset everything and we
put back the tiles to zero and because
we put our current while loop to zero
before regenerating it's going to
regenerate
coordinates starting at zero so let's
try it and also you see that because we
call these two functions
we can also replace these two lines by
reset game so we can do that it's not
going to change anything but we can
change the code like this let's try it i
start the game i lose and i can click
again and the game is restarting from
the top okay everything is working fine
and let's continue
let's finalize our menu first thing we
want to do is to put the right title and
the right text for the button so when we
will start we want to display galaxy for
the title and start for the button and
also when we will be in game over we
will change the title by game over and
the text button by restart so how can we
do that if i go back to the menu we have
our label with default text and the
button with the text so you may say i
can put galaxy here as a default text
and then put an id on this label and get
a property to
change the text of my label but we can
do something easier than this we can
directly put a string property here for
the title and that's what we are going
to do i'm going to write menu title and
it's a property we are going to define
in the main widget so it's going to be
root not parent dot menu title and we
are going to do the same for the button
it's going to be menu button title so i
have to define that in my main widget
here i will say menu title is a string
property so i need to import that and i
will do the same for the menu
button title i can give a default value
here so the default value is going to be
galaxy and it's going to be start for
the button also for the title we want to
expand a bit the different letters so
i'm going to put three spaces between
every letters let's try it so i have
galaxy and start button but when i'm in
game over i want to display game over
and restart so let's do that i have to
change the value of menu title and menu
button title
when we get the game over at the end of
the update function
here so i'm going to make self dot menu
title equal game over and self dot menu
button title equal restart
and for the game over i'm going to
expand the letters but only by two
spaces this time because this word is
longer in the middle i put four
and two okay let's try start and
game over restart okay it's working well
so now let's add some style to our menu
and you will need to use the file i gave
you in the resource folder that you can
download you will find three folders
audio with the different sounds that we
will add later now we will use the fonts
so it's going to be this font for the
title and euro still for the button and
also you will get the background image
so let's copy these three folders at the
root of your project you can use a right
click on a file and this option reveal
in finder and then you just copy your
three folders here it will appear in the
project okay
so let's use this font for the title how
can we use a custom font for the label
we use font name and we need to give the
directory which is fonts
slash and this name of file suckers go
tick std light dot ttf okay and also we
are going to make bigger letters so it's
going to be a font size
and let's put 60
dp okay let's try it so that looks nice
for the title let's style the button for
the button i'm going to use also these
two properties font size that you are
going to put half 30 and for the font
name i'm going to use the other font
your row still okay
so what do we have this time we have
something that looks great i want to
expand a bit the height of the button
and also to position it a bit lower and
we will add some color to this button so
first thing the size is ten percent
height i'm going to give 15 percent and
i want to display it a bit lower so i'm
going to put it at 30 percent of the
screen now i want to add a background
color so i can use a background color
and i prepare the color code for
something quite red so it's going to be
100 red and 30 percent green
40 percent blue and i put it at 85
percent opacity so let's try that and
you can see that my color is not really
vivid it's because it is multiplied by
the default button column which is a
gray so to remove this texture we need
to use background normal and to reset
the texture and this time it's going to
look nice ok
perfect i can start my game and then i
get game over everything is good
concerning the menu
for this exercise i'm going to ask you
to display the background image this one
bg1.jpg in the background of the main
widget so we just place the game above
all of this you will need to add this
image in the main widget but you are
going to add that in the kv file here
i don't give you more instructions it's
your turn to do the exercise and then i
will show you the solution
[Music]
can we display this image can we use an
image here not really because the image
is going to be drawn over the canva so
we need to display it in the background
and what we can use is a canvas before
and inside we will use a rectangle that
will use this file as a texture so we
will use the source property on a
rectangle that will take all the window
and because we are in canvas before it's
the first thing we are going to draw on
the screen and we will draw everything
else on top and that's what we want to
do so i'm going to put a rectangle that
will take all the space so it's going to
be a size of self dot size and i will
use the source image
images
slash vg1 dot jpeg let's try it you can
see that the image is displayed and i
can start the game okay everything is
correct let's continue on the project
let's display the score in our game
what is the score and what will be the
score in our case i have decided that
the score will be the number of loop
defines how long we could go into the
pass so it's going to increment and it's
going to be finally the value of the
score so where can we display the score
i want to display the score in the game
window at the top left and we are going
to add it directly in the main widget so
first we will write some code together
and after you will do an exercise so i
go to the galaxy.kv and i want to add a
label should i add the score label
before the menu widget or after it it's
going to be an important choice but i'm
going to start by putting it before the
menu widget label for the text i'm just
going to try with a placeholder text
it's going to be score
120 for example and also i'm going to
put a style so for the style i'm going
to copy paste these two lines from the
button of the menu and i'm going to
paste it here i'm going to use a font
size of 20 and to keep this font name er
still so what does it makes right now if
i start it i cannot see it but if i
start the game you can see that the
score is displayed in the middle of the
screen because it takes all the space
so we need to define the size hint for
example 20
and
20
okay so what do we have we have
something here
but i want to display it at the top left
so i'm going to use
a pos hint
that will be
x
0 so that one was implicit that was
already here but most important is to
have the top
to one totally at the top so let's see
yes it's displayed here so that's
correct and i just want to reduce a bit
of margins here so i will reduce a
little bit the size to 18
okay so we have something good and when
we start the game we will display the
score so it's going to be your exercise
you need to display the real score here
and you will use a property for the text
that we will call score txt okay
because we are in the main widget we are
going to use root dot directly we don't
use root parent we needed to use parent
from the menu because the parent of the
menu is the main widget but since we are
in the main widget directly it's going
to be root score txt for this exercise
you will define this new property and in
this property you will need to use the
value of the current loop to display the
actual score do this exercise on your
side and when it's done i will show you
the solution
[Music]
so what we need to do is to define this
score property i go to the main widget
at the top and here i will define string
property because we need to display
score and then the value of the score
score text is going to change when we
change the value of the loop so i go
back in the update function here when we
increment the current while loop and we
are going to do the score equal to score
and then the value of this current while
okay let's try that so you can see that
at the beginning i don't see the score
because we did not give a default value
for the property okay but when i start
it i get one two three four five and we
begin to see the score and when i have a
game over i can still see the score but
not really well because of the overlay
of the menu and also if i click on
restart you can see i still see 23 and
then one two three four five so i want
to display score zero and display score
zero we are going to put this line also
in the reset function so it's going to
be more clean here i can put score zero
directly and remove that part or i can
keep that part and because current while
loop is reset to zero it's going to make
the same thing okay let's try it so this
time you can see i see score zero when i
start i have zero one two three and when
i lose i have again 0 1 2 3. it's more
clean now i want to change something i
want to see the score correctly because
here we cannot see it much because of
the overlay how can we solve that
finally in the galaxy.kb we need to
display the label on top of the menu and
not the opposite so if i
do that this way i'm going to display
the score on top of the menu so it's
always displayed correctly okay that's
all for this exercise
let's play the sounds in our game you
see in the audio folder that we have
many wave sounds so we are going to play
these sounds in our game and at first
i'm going to write some code with you
and for the exercise you will trigger
the sounds at the right moment so let's
initialize the sounds we will create a
new function init audio and we will use
the sound
loader dot load and give the name of the
function sound loader you need to import
it from tv core audio sound loader here
we need to give the name of the
different files so i will start with the
first one
begin dot wave and i need to provide
the directory name so it's going to be
audio slash begin.wave and this sound we
need to save it in a variable so we can
use play or stop on this variable later
so it's going to be a self dot
sound
begin equal this
i will need to define all my different
variables here none okay
so i need to copy paste this line for
every sound that we have so we have
still one two three four five other
sounds okay and i will copy paste and i
will write down
the name of the different files you can
see i have a completion here
game over impact
game over voice
music one
why i call it music one because maybe
you will want to add some more music in
the game later so i just call it music
one instead of music and restart
okay so let's rename the variables
galaxy game over impact
game over voice music one
and restart and i will copy all of this
so i can create the
different variables equal none so begin
we have it galaxy equal none impact
voice
music and restart okay and i will remove
the self in the front perfect
so now my init audio function i need to
call it from the init of the game so i
will call it at first init audio okay
and i'm going to add something we can
control the volume of the different
sounds so for the music sound music 1 we
can do dot volume equal 1 is the maximum
it's 100 percent for all the voices like
begin galaxy and and the other ones you
are going to give a volume of 25 percent
so i will copy paste that and for the
sound galaxy i'm going to do the same
this is an impact song and this one is a
voice sound and restart also okay for
the sound of impact we are going to give
60
so you can adjust the volume of the
different sounds for me i will keep
these values now it's your turn you have
to do an exercise you need to trigger
the different sounds at the right moment
so you will need to call the play
function and also sometimes the stop
function the galaxy voice is called
totally at the beginning when we start
the game it will say galaxy and when we
will press start
it will say
begin okay and it will also start the
music
then later when you will get a game over
you will play the impact of the sound
and you will also need to stop the music
and you will also play the game over
voice but then the button now is not
start it's restart so when the user will
click on the restart button you will
need to play restart sound it's your
turn to practice and when it's done i
will show you the solution
[Music]
so first thing i will do is i will use
this begin sound the begging sound is
when we click on the button on menu
button pressed okay i can play my sound
when i click on the button let's try it
here i press start and it says begin but
i have a problem in the game over i'm
going to click on the same button and i
want to say restart but it says begin
because here we need to test the state
if
we are in
state game over
then we will play the restart sound else
i'm in the first case and i will play
sound begin let's try that okay begin
game over
begin so it's not working and why it's
not working because you remember that we
already reset the state game over in the
reset function so we don't have that
information anymore we need to move this
part of code before the reset function
so we have still this state game over
let's try it begin okay restart okay
that's correct
now let's start the music when we click
on this button we are going to start the
music so i'm going to do sound music one
dot play okay and i'm going to group all
the sounds together so i'm going to play
it here so whether we are in the first
case or in the game over we are going to
play the music when we click in the
button in every case okay it's working
but in the game over i want to stop
playing the music
so when we get the game over we have
multiple things to do we need to stop
the music stop but we also need to play
some other sounds because we have the
sound of impact game over impact that we
are going to play and we have also the
voice
sound game of our voice that we need to
play so let's see what it gives and i
got to crash let's see why
float object has no attribute play and
we get a problem on that sound game over
impact it says it's a float object why i
think i know why it's when we put the
volume i think i forgot to put volume in
front let's see init audio and here you
see
sound game over impact dot
volume is equal to zero six okay let's
try again and then you could hear
the music stop i get the impact sound
and we also hear the game over that was
quite low and we are going to improve
that later i'm going to show you how to
delay the sound but just to finish the
exercise i need also to play the galaxy
sound at the beginning so i'm going to
take that and on the init of the game
after init audio i will put it at the
end of the init function
i will play
the galaxy sound so when i start the
game we can hear galaxy then we can
start and then i get the game of
restart game over okay so that's all for
the exercise and now i'm going to show
you how to improve it a little bit i
want to have the impact sound on the
game over immediately
but a few seconds later like three
seconds later i want to play the sound
game over so let's do that when i get my
game over i'm in the update function
here so when i play game of voice
that's voice on i want to delay it
so i'm going to define a new function
play
game over
voice
sound okay so we are going to play the
sound and this function we need to delay
it from here so i'm going to use clock
dot schedule
once we want to start it only one time
this function
self dot play game over voice sound okay
and i will specify the delay for example
three seconds and because this function
is used inside the schedule function i
need to give the delta time parameter so
let's try it
so you could hear i got the impact and
then a few seconds later we could hear
game over but in fact we have a small
look for example if i restart
you can hear game over while i'm playing
the game and this is because when we get
the game over we trigger that function
that will happen three seconds later
okay so we trigger that but before it
happens
i click quickly on the button here so i
had time to restart the game and when
i'm playing then after a few seconds
this is going to play so i will hear
game over
while i'm playing so this is clearly a
bug so what we can do is to test here if
we are still in a game of our state if
self dot state
game over then only in that case i will
play the game of the song let's try it
again and you can hear that this time i
didn't hear the game of her song i will
only hear it when i wait
this one so everything is good for our
game you have completed the galaxy
project and you have reached the end of
this tutorial congratulations you might
ask me so now where do i go from here
what's next
i advise you to practice by doing some
personal projects
let me share with you some ideas why not
creating a simple game or a simple
application like a currency converter or
a password generator or why not trying
to add some features to the galaxy game
for example store and display the best
score or manage multiple levels or
increase the speed over time or other
difficulty choice easy medium hard
and also we can stay in touch you can
subscribe to my youtube channel code
with jonathan so that you will know when
i post new tutorials and if you like to
learn from me you can check out my full
python course that includes more than
300 videos and 27 hours of content
thanks again and see you soon